a in the past month
because they could not afford to eat
seven million families had to skip a
meal
and that was true of nearly half of
those on universal credit
this is not just about families out of
work but families in work too
this is a social emergency
and it is also a looming economic threat
depriving our economy of the spending
power it needs
and the question at the heart of this
debate madam deputy speaker is whether
this gracious speech this government and
yes this chancellor is up to the
challenge this emergency represents
now the chancellor wants us to believe
that his measures in response are the
best we can do
but they are not
not by a long shot
the cost of living crisis is driven most
of all by what is happening to energy
bills let's look at the three chances
he's had in the last seven months to act
on energy bills madam deputy speaker it
was last august
last august nine months ago that the
first energy price rise was announced
139 pound increase in the price cap so
way back then he knew what was happening
and then in october he delivered his
budget wholesale energy prices were
rocketing the warning signals were
flashing but the chancellor did nothing
mr speak madam david speaker i believe
you should go back and reread that
budget speech because i think it would
make even him
wince
it is a model of complacency
he drunk his own kool-aid this is what
he told the country back then and i
quote wages are rising growth up a
government ready and willing to act on
inflation the plan is working where are
we now madame deputy speaker on wages
the office for budget responsibility is
this year forecasting the biggest fall
in living standards in 45 years
growth turned negative in march with the
bank of england suggesting the economy
is going to shrink through the winter
and on inflation we are now set for the
highest level of inflation for 40 years
mr madam deputy speaker the plan isn't
working it is failing
and he didn't i i will i'll make some
more progress but i will give way and he
didn't act when he could have done
in february another chance he had as the
largest energy price rise in our history
52
was announced he could have responded
commensurate with the crisis but what
was he says he did well let's go let's
let's look at it what was his grand
offer to the country 100 150 pounds
council tax discount based on outdated
property values which misses out
hundreds of thousands of the poorest
families
and of course i will in a moment and of
course his 200 pound buy now pay later
loan scheme
a loan scheme a loan scheme adam deputy
speaker which he risibly claims isn't
alone although it has to be paid back
and a scheme that doesn't even come into
october
madam deputy speaker what a family
supposed to do in the meantime while
they wait for his loan
it's almost like the chancellor is so
out of touch that he doesn't realize
that 10 million families in our country
have no savings at all i'll give way to
the honorable gentleman
from giving way the 150 pounds that was
be given out by newcastle underlying
council was greatly received on the
doorsteps as was the money given out by
westminster council perhaps he should
speak to his council leaders in barrow
heinbern south derbyshire basically all
councils that failed to get that 150
pounds out of the people's bank accounts
if he's so concerned about the cost of
living why are his council leaders
holding that money in their bank account
instead of returning it to the people
anticipate the later part of my speech
that is the conservative party today
they'll blame anyone else and they'll
never take responsibility
and madam deputy speaker he should have
been supporting our measures because in
his constituency eleven thousand three
hundred and fifty three people would get
our combination of a vh cut and the warm
homes discount of 600 pounds and if he
votes against us tonight he'll have to
explain to them why he is denying them
the help they need
for giving way he's making a powerful
speech i wonder if he shares my anger at
news this week that the government has
underspent its net zero budget by a
staggering quarter of a billion pounds
at exactly the same time when our
constituents are struggling to keep
their homes warm and to deal with with
accelerating fuel poverty
they agree with the honorable lady at
every step of the way they've had the
chance to act and they haven't i give
way to honourable gentlemen i think they
always have that for giving away
the figures for northern ireland very
interesting 241 uh 100
thirty percent of people in poverty in
northern seventy percent of all children
in poverty fourteen percent of all
pensioners in poverty eleven percent of
all working age population and poverty
those figures scare me to scare you
i think the honourable gentleman is
absolutely right i've been around
politics for a long time as this house
knows but i cannot remember and nobody
in this house can remember the kind of
emergency that we are facing
at the moment now his recent strength
spring statement madam deputy speaker
was the most recent chance for the
chancellor to redeem himself days before
the april energy price rise came into
effect
madam deputy speaker it was apparent to
everyone across this house and in the
country that what he had offered was
woefully inadequate people were
literally pleading with him to do more
on energy bills but he just doubled down
on his failure three chances in the last
seven months none of them equal to the
emergency and and i and i i will in a
moment and at every step of the way the
truth about this chancellor is that he
has been in denial he has been slow to
act and he has been wholly out of touch
in his response i give way to the
honourable lady
we can do but will he accept that the
measures we put forward in terms of the
national living wage in terms of
universal credit and in terms of the
national insurance threshold changes
adds up to more than what he is
suggesting
no i don't accept that and i can tell
her there are 8014 families in her
constituency that would benefit from the
changes that we are suggesting if she
votes for them tonight now let me tell
her and the house madame david this is
very important what this failure means
in reality
the basic level
of universal credit
this year
for a single person
over 25
is
334 pounds a month
his measures this april
are so feeble
that someone on that benefit
will be expected to find
as much as 50 pounds more a month or
more
to simply cover the increase in their
energy bills
that's leaving aside the soaring costs
of food and other goods
it's about 15
of their income
so what are they going to do
they won't be able to afford to pay
their bills
they will get deeply
into debt
and they will go
without food
it's already happening
to millions
i met someone in a cab in the cab in my
constituency on friday in similar
circumstances let me be honest madam
deputy speaker
i would have no idea
how i would cope
in these circumstances
would any member of this house
maybe the chancellor can tell us
what somebody in these circumstances
is supposed to do
and mr speaker
if you're the chancellor of the
exchequer madam deputy speaker if you're
the chancellor of the exchequer and you
can't answer that question it should
tell you something that you are failing
in your duty to the people of this
country who most need your help and of
course and of course madam deputy
speaker what makes him even more
culpable is that there is something that
could help staring him right in the face
where the case has become unanswerable
where the government has run out of
excuses where oil and gas producers are
making billions a windfall tax
now he's it's so hard to keep track of
what the government's position is on
this madam deputy speaker that i've
given up but he i think he said i think
he said he's prepared to look at it but
but honestly
the british people can't afford to wait
for him and his dithering anymore or his
hopeless excuses and i want to go
through the hopeless excuses because
this is an important argument that this
house and this country needs to have
what are their excuses for not doing a
windfall tax right first they said in
january that oil and gas companies were
and i quote
struggling in the words of the education
secretary struggling
bp the highest profits for a decade
shell its highest profit ever the boss
of bernard looney describing the price
hike as a cash machine
and these people
say the companies are struggling maybe
we can do a show of hands if anyone
opposite still believes that the
companies are struggling are they
struggling
what's their next excuse they argue a
windfall tax would hurt investment but
the pr oh it will he says oh he says
it's from a sedentary position right
okay here we go
but the problem is the problem is the
companies themselves say this is
nonsense
bp's ceo who i take is more of an
authority than the honorable gentleman
bernard looney was asked two weeks ago
which investments he wouldn't proceed
with if a windfall tax was lobbied was
levied and what was his answer
there are none we wouldn't do
even bp
don't buy the tory arguments against the
windfall tax on bp
and the final excuse and the final
issues that i'm going to make some
progress the final excuse and i want i
do want to come to this because this is
important and maybe i'm anticipating the
chancellor the final excuse is it's
somehow anti-business to levy a windfall
tax let's dispose of this argument too
and i strongly recommend to honorable
members
who believe this to read an article
which i have here and i'm happy to put a
copy in the library of the house and
it's by mr erwin steltzer long-time
confidant of rupert murdoch this is the
first time i've quoted him uh in this
house madame deputy speaker in an
article entitled a few days ago
now is the time for a win for profits
tax he wrote this
people who believe in capitalism believe
that private sector companies
should be rewarded for taking risks
not be rewarded for happening to be
around when some disruption drives up
prices producing windfalls
and that is the point these profits are
unearned unexpected and the british
people are paying for this windfall
these these companies these companies
are not profiting from these companies
are not profiting from decisions they
have made risks they have taken wealth
they've created but from a global spike
in prices to which britain is badly
exposed exacerbated by putin's invasion
of ukraine
what is the principle the government is
defending here what is their hill to die
on
is the principle they really wish to
defend the oil and gas companies should
pocket any profits however bad the
geopolitical instability
that however large the crisis however
gigantic the windfall
taxation
must not change
madam deputy speaker
this is a proposition rejected
by margaret thatcher
jeffrey howe
george osborne
remember him all of all of whom levied
winful taxes and who else do we see
supporting a windfall tax today i have
to say it's a pretty big tent uh madame
deputy speaker john allen the guy who
runs tesco
sharon white the woman who runs john
lewis
lord brown
the guy who used to run bp
and lord hague
the guy who used to run the conservative
party
the usu the usual lefty suspect
the truth is they have run out of
excuses
and admits the amidst the chaos and
confusion about what their position is i
think a massive u-turn is lumbering
slowly over the hill
but i say this to the chancellor
swallow your pride and get on with it
because every day he delays is another
day when the british people are denied
the help they need millions of families
having sleepless nights because the
chancellor won't like what is he waiting
for he should come to the house as
proposed by my right honourable friend
the shadow chancellor with an emergency
budget for a windfall tax getting rid of
v80 on energy bills an increase in the
warm homes discount to 400 pounds an
emergency plan to insulate two million
homes this year and a cut-in business
rate and their position their position
on the windfall tax madam deputy speaker
it's part of a i won't for a moment and
their position on the windfall tax is
part of a wider problem with this
chancellor and this government just look
at the political choices he is making he
leaves non-doms shielding their millions
while millions of families and
pensioners face a cut in their incomes
he whacks up taxes on tenants and lets
landlords off the hook he makes young
people at work pay more but those
getting money from capital gains pay not
a penny extra wrong unfair unjust out of
touch that's who he is
now of course i won't give away that now
of course being this government they
always try and blame
someone else we heard it earlier on
in just the last few days alone
and he in just the last few days alone
madam deputy speaker here is the roll
call of people the party opposite are
trying to frame i have to say it's hard
to keep track
the bank of england
civil servants working from home
shamefully the british people being
unable to cook properly apparently the
cause of food banks
yesterday
a ludicrous suggestion for one of these
ministers people not working enough
hours
and the chancellor and the chancellor of
all people is at it too
who does he blame for the massive cut to
benefits
he blames
the i.t system
the dude from silicon valley madam
deputy speaker who is he trying to kid
if he had got his act together early
enough of course he could have raised
benefits properly
indeed the thing i don't get is this he
found it perfectly possible to cut
universal credit by 20 pounds in the
middle of the year in september madame
deputy speaker it's not a case of
computer says no it's the case of
chancellor says no it's not the case of
a computer system not being up to it
it's the chancellor not being up to it
mr speaker the story of the last few
months
crypto has crashed and so has the
chancellor and how similar they are the
chancellor and cryptocurrency
came out of nowhere
the value surged
looked like the future
but it all turned out to be one giant
ponzi scheme
he's just been found out he's been
rumbled and let's be honest his
colleagues all know it
he's out of touch with what is happening
in the country he's out of ideas when it
comes to doing the right thing and he is
out of his depth when it comes to the
challenges this country is facing
and the problem of course
and the problem of course is that
today's cost of living crisis
doesn't stand alone it comes on top of a
decade of failure madam deputy speaker
that's why families in our economy are
so vulnerable
growth over the last 12 years
averaged just 1.4
percent the worst of any government
since the second world war
the worst decade for living standards
since the 1920s
according to the ifs
indeed wages would have been seven
thousand pounds higher on average than
they are today if wage growth had
matched the rate of the last labor
government taxes at the highest level
since the 1950s public services
struggling never have so many paid so
much for so little 12 years of tory
economics have failed and what does he
offer in the future he offers more of
the fame
anemic growth just 1.7 squeezed wages as
far as the eye can see
madam deputy speaker this is the plan
for growth we need tackling the cost of
living crisis so people have more money
in their pockets an industrial strategy
so we have good jobs in the industries
of the future that is what governments
all around the world are doing and we
need a plan madam deputy speaker to give
people proper rights to boost wages at
work to make our economy fair
where is the employment bill promised in
2019
and still not here they may mouth the
words of being on the side of workers
but their actions tell the real story
i'm going to i'm going to wind up i'm
going to wind up these
magic okay i'll give way to him okay
i'm glad he mentioned jobs on the day
that we saw unemployment fall to its
lowest level and actually the number of
people out of work is now lower than the
number of vacancies in the economy but
he just made an extraordinary number of
unfunded spending commitments at the
dispatch board
and i just want to take him to the big
difference between his side
and the chancellor i remember the spring
statement the shadow chancellor made a
commitment
to raise
benefits early and she said it cost no
money it actually cost 24
000 million pounds across the spending
period no sense of how to pay for it
that's labor start finish and end yeah
it's good to see he's clambered back on
the career bandwagon i thought he was no
longer a loyalist the truth is it's
actually the resolution fan it's
actually the it's actually the
resolution foundation that pointed that
out uh and i can give him the reference
madam deputy speaker i'm gonna wind up
these are the basics of a modern economy
but this government is failing on all of
them no cost of living plan no growth
plan no plan for rights at work they
haven't learned the mistakes of the last
decade and they are condemned to repeat
them the truth about this gracious
speech is it does not remotely rise to
the short or long term challenges the
british people face
but i end by saying this this house can
make a difference tonight
and i say to this to his mps directly we
have all heard from our own
constituencies what families are facing
this is an emergency for millions of
people people
a windfall tax could make a difference
use no one use this opportunity to tell
the chancellor to act it is the right
thing to do it's the fair thing to do
the case is unanswerable and if they do
not they will have to explain to their
constituents why they refuse to support
the help that could make a difference
now i urge members to vote for our
amendment tonight to help tackle the
social emergency our country is facing
[Applause]
the original question was that a humble
address be presented to her majesty as
on the order paper
since when amendment v has been proposed
as on the order paper the question is
that the amendment be made chancellor of
the exchequer rishi sooner
thank you madam deputy speaker i'm proud
to speak today in support of a queen
speech that will both ease the cost of
living with billions of pounds of
support for families and madame deputy
speaker grow the economy creating more
jobs more investment and higher wages
management speaker
the imf the oecd and the world bank have
all warned that high inflation is the
most acute challenge facing not just the
uk but the global economy we are not
alone in facing these challenges kovit
has disrupted supply chains putin's
invasion in ukraine has exacerbated the
shock in energy prices businesses are
facing shortages the cause of madam
deputy speaker are indeed global but of
course the consequences are being felt
here at home families up and down the
country are being hit hard by the rising
prices of fuel of food and of heating
i cannot say to people that this will be
easy the next few months will be
difficult there is no measure any
government can take no law we can pass
that can make these global forces
disappear overnight no honest chancellor
could stand here and promise prices will
not rise further or that the government
can cover every extra pound on people's
bills but
i will in a second but to suggest as we
have heard today that there is no help
available as some have said today is
both misleading madam deputy speaker and
irresponsible
the chancellor for giving away the other
day he said he couldn't increase
benefits because of i.t problems at the
start of the pandemic quite rightly he
increased universal credit by 20 pounds
a week will he do that again
yeah yeah
madam deputy speaker the uh the oral
gentleman will know perhaps better than
me given his own experience that there
are multiple different benefits on
multiple different systems and whilst
universal credit does have the
flexibility
of being changed at different times a
policy by the way that the party
opposite opposed at every step of the
way the remainder of benefits and
pensions cannot be upgraded mid-year and
he will know that and i'm sure my uh
honourable friend will speak to that
later but i'm glad to see that he does
support universal credit and that is one
of the things that this government is
proud of introducing that it can respond
in the crisis as it so admirably did i'm
happy to take the honourable gentleman
i'm very grateful to the chancellor from
what he's just said he's just admitted
that he could increase your universal
credit by 20 pounds so why doesn't he do
it yeah yeah
well madam deputy speaker because we
want to make sure that we get support to
everyone in a way that suits him what we
did do last autumn is actually we heard
about this from the honourable gentleman
where he gave a case study on universal
credit what did we do in universal
credit we cut the universal credit taper
rate by the biggest amount that had ever
been cut that was that was the biggest
tax cut for people in low incomes that
we have seen
and in contrast to the cherry-picked
example that we heard from the
honourable gentleman opposite what does
that mean madam deputy speaker what does
it mean for a single mother on universal
credit working on the national living
wage with two children renting it means
that that mum is going to be 1600 pounds
a year better off this year that's what
this government is doing madam deputy
speaker so help is there and anyone
seeking to pretend otherwise is simply
causing more worry and more anxiety
i thank my wonderful friend for giving
away and i do think there's no
recognition on the other side of the 22
billion pounds the government put in to
help with the cost of living
particularly with the uh 5p cut in
in fields
um
but i just asked my uh my honourable
friend that the oil companies are not
passing the cuts to the pumps they don't
um reduce the price they take ages to
reduce the prices when the international
oil price falls the oil bosses are
earning multi-million pound salaries and
getting a multi-million pound bonuses
they are in essence in my view the new
oligarchs
and i would urge him not to consider
both the windfall tax on the oil
companies which we can then use to cut
taxes for the lower paid or cut energy
bills and also introduce a pump watch
monitor
to make sure that there's fair
competition that consumers get a fair
deal at the pumps but i genuinely
recognize all the work that he has done
thus far to try and cut the cost of
living
thank my honorable friend um for his
advice and support and i will come on to
both of his points momentarily in fact
but he's right uh to remind the house
that so far we have provided 22 billion
pounds of direct support this is not
madam deputy speaker a trivial figure
it's 22 billion pounds of support to
help families up and down our country at
a time of challenge and we have taken
action as we heard to cut people's birth
starting with fuel duty and i commend my
honorable friend for his campaigns on
this cut by five pence a leader worth a
hundred pounds this year together with
the freeze council tax cut by a hundred
and fifty pounds and i think what the
honorable gentleman opposite didn't
mention the right law gentlemen opposite
that that 150 pounds of support which as
we heard from my honourable friend at
behind is made a huge difference to
families
came faster than any support that the
labour party was offering in their
proposal in size and it went to a far
broader group of people than their
proposal because we did want to support
those on middle incomes as well uh vat
which would have worth about i think
eight pounds a month at the time madam
deputy speaker this is 150 pounds in
people's bank accounts in april we also
cut the tape rate in universal credit as
i said giving an extra thousand pounds
to the average household the warm homes
discount increased to 150 pounds the
national living wage as we heard
increased giving low paid workers a pay
rise of a thousand pounds and madam
deputy speaker we will go further
i want to come back to what you said
earlier in his speech we spoke about and
the crisis around the cove the
government acted quickly can i just ask
the chancellor does he recognize that
many of our constituents are in a crisis
at the moment i know he's installing a
new swimming pool in the house but i can
tell the people in glasgow east are very
much struggling and his government needs
to do more
madam deputy speaker this government has
always acted to protect this country at
times of challenge as we have done
through the past two years and we did
continue to do so now and as we said
nine billion pounds of support on energy
bills announced in february at the same
time as the price cap was increased and
it covered 50 of the rise in bills
accepting being honest with the house as
we discussed at the time that no
government could cover every pound of an
increase when we're in a situation with
global inflationary forces and it would
be both irresponsible and misleading to
pretend to the british public that that
was possible
but madam deputy speaker we are going
further in october a further discount on
energy bills worth 200 pounds and in
just a few weeks time a massive tax cut
for workers when the national insurance
threshold is increased to 12 and a half
thousand pounds that is a six billion
pound tax cut for working people the
biggest increase in a personal tax
threshold ever and it will mean that
everyone in this country can earn 12 and
a half thousand pounds without paying a
penny of income tax or national
insurance and this does mean in contrast
again to what we heard that 70
of working people will pay less tax this
year than they did last year
taken together madam deputy speaker all
of those measures i've just mentioned
equate to a 22 billion pound plan to
help cut costs for families and help
people with the cost of living and of
course as the situation evolves our
response will also evolve i have always
been clear we stand ready to do more and
madam deputy speaker that does bring me
to the topic of a windfall tax now
unlike the party opposite we on this
side of the house don't believe that
windfall taxes are the simple and easy
answer to every problem
but but we are pragmatic
and what we want to see are energy
companies who have made extraordinary
profits at a time of acutely elevated
prices investing those profits back into
british jobs growth and energy security
but as i have been clear and as i have
said repeatedly if that doesn't happen
soon and at significant scale then no
option is off the table
madam deputy speaker global economic
forces are indeed hitting the british
people hard and that's why the
government is stepping in to help but
ultimately but ultimately over the long
term we on this side of the house know
that the best way to raise living
standards is to grow the economy
and that's why our economic plan and
this queen's speech will create more
jobs more investment and crucially
higher wages
during the pandemic we provided billions
of support not just to the economy but
specifically to businesses because of
schemes like the furlough we were able
to keep millions and millions of people
in work
and the success of our plan for jobs is
clear as we heard from our honorable
friend unemployment right now is the
lowest it has been in almost half a
century
job vacancies the highest they have ever
been total pay rising in real terms and
over four percent higher than before the
pandemic even adjusted for the inflation
that we are seeing madam deputy speaker
that doesn't happen by accident it is
the result of a responsible conservative
government delivering a stronger economy
an economy which grew faster last year
than any of our competitors
and this strong recovery
is making a difference to people's
finances
taken together the combination i will in
a second the combination of policy
measures the government has announced
and the growth in the economy
offset around half the shock to incomes
caused by higher global energy and goods
prices
half of that shock offset by the result
of our actions to grow the economy and
support people directly
now of course we do need to do more to
create further economic growth and
that's why this queen's speech brings
forward measures to do exactly that i'll
take the ladies
well gentleman's forgiving way given
that he was just talking about growth in
the economy he will be aware that the
governor of the bank of england and the
monetary policy committee
told the treasury select committee
yesterday that growth would actually be
negative
this year in the fourth quarter growth
is slowing unemployment is rising and
inflation is soaring is that not correct
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think the honourable lady i think she
said unemployment is is rising no it
just fell this morning to the lowest
level in almost half a century i'll come
on to our growth figures in in just a
second but we have had a strong recovery
and a forecast to continue uh growing
strongly relative to peers as well but
we do need to do more madam deputy
speaker and that's why the queen's
speech brings forward measures to boost
our national infrastructure to level up
to back financial services one of our
biggest and most successful sectors
employing millions of people right
across the country to cut red tape to
use our new brexit freedoms to bank
british businesses to reform higher
education and to strengthen our energy
security
and we on this side of the house know
that over the longer term the best way
to create that growth is to have an
economy where businesses can invest more
train more and innovate more
i'm grateful to the chancellor for
giving way
while he is still considering a windfall
tax i just want to tell him about one
constituent of mine who got in touch
who's 62 year old woman in walton
she decided to disconnect from british
gas for fear of a bill coming through
the door in a few months time
well i'm very sorry to hear of the
circumstances individual concerned i'd
be happy to talk to her directly if that
would help but i hope that he in his
role can explain to her the support that
is in place to help families like her
whether it's the direct whether it's the
direct support with her energy bills
whether it's 150 pounds whether it's the
fact that she her national living wage
may well be increased depending on her
situation and indeed as as my ronald
friend reminds me to talk to her local
council to access the household support
fund which is there being doubled to a
billion pounds to provide direct support
to those who are most vulnerable uh man
of speech i'm now going to make some
progress it our plan is to build that
economy of the future and that's why
this autumn we will cut taxes on capital
on people and ideas to drive up growth
and support businesses to do so
and while we're talking about growth we
have heard a lot during these debates
and i think the honourable uh general
nerdy mentioned it as well about the
labor growth that we experienced between
97 and 2010 now it was obviously a very
long time ago that we last had a labor
government so let me remind the house of
the facts
under the labour government the uk's
cumulative economic growth was third in
the g7
and under this government in spite of
having lived through the worst recession
in over 300 years our cumulative growth
is also third in the g7 and madam deputy
speaker let's also remember that when
the opposition last arrived in office
unemployment was seven percent but when
they left 13 years later
it was of course higher eight percent
new figures as we've heard this morning
show that the uk's unemployment rate is
now less than half of that the lowest in
half a century but the story also madame
deputy speaker is the same on the public
finances the deficit in 97 2
of gdp
by 2010 it was nearly 10
one pound in every four the government
spent was borrowed there was as we heard
no money left
speaking to what the chancellor is
saying that also under this conservative
government we introduced the
living wage which has increased wages
for the poorest in our country at a
higher rate than the last labour
government ever had the courage to do
absolutely and we now have the lowest
unemployment rate for 50 years yeah yeah
my
my remember my honorable friend is
absolutely right the increase this year
in the national living wage worth a
thousand pounds of someone working
full-time on the national living wage
that will benefit millions of those
particularly on the low income that is
our priority and that is our values but
that approach to borrowing that i
describe manageable speaker is not the
approach of this responsible
conservative government today despite
having spent hundreds of billions
through the pandemic providing the
highest sustained level of public sector
investment in decades and re investing
record amounts in public services like
the nhs this government is on track to
have borrowing low and debt falling
again that is our record madam deputy
speaker robust growth
more jobs and being responsible with the
country's finances so madam deputy
speaker let me close with one final
point history reminds us that at times
like now when we face severe supply
problems an unconstrained fiscal
stimulus risks making the problem worse
prices pushed up still further
expectations of higher inflation
becoming ingrained a vicious cycle
leading inexorably to even higher
interest rates and more pain for tens of
millions of mortgage holders and small
businesses
make no mistake
simply trying to borrow and spend our
way out of this situation is the wrong
approach and those paying the highest
price would be the poorest in our
society
instead on this side of the house we are
taking a careful deliberate approach we
will act to cut costs for those people
make it without making the situation
worse we will continue to back people
who work hard as we always have and we
will do more to support the most
vulnerable and unlike others we will not
simply borrow our way out
so yes we are helping families by
cutting their costs and it is
irresponsible to suggest otherwise but
that support will always be part of a
broader plan that will grow the economy
encourage investment and create more
high-skilled high-wage jobs all built on
the foundation of strong public finances
that madam deputy speaker is our
economic plan we are providing 22
billion pounds of support to help
families with the cost of living we are
creating more jobs more investment and
higher wages that is what this queen's
speech is all about and i commend it to
the house
[Applause]
before we move on um i should say that
there are obviously a lot of colleagues
wishing to get in so there will be a
five minute time limit on back bench
speech speeches uh snp spokesperson alan
brown
thank you madam david speaker i'd like
to say it's a pleasure to follow a
chance for about we just have 16 minutes
more of platitudes and no new ideas now
some of the things the chancellor said
he said people on these side of the
adventures are causing people more worry
or say the chance of what's causing
people worry is not having enough
pockets money in their pockets to pay
their bills it's nothing to do with what
we say here it's what they see in
reality
now
mentioned yet again is nine billion
pound support package for energy bills
what it doesn't say is only a third of
that is money that comes from the
treasury that won't record back two
thirds of that nine billion pounds is
added to our energy bills and recovered
through our bills so he's making bills
higher for other people while at least
providing some crumbs of support to the
most vulnerable he mentioned growing the
economy while saying without uh well
ducking this year the the last figures
there showed that march
the economy was already starting to
contract and then for good measure at
the end we have have some bluster about
labor's past record it's stuff to hide
the issues what that does also tell us
by the way madame dev speaker is at
westminster has not been working for a
very long time
now as at the election of duty for the
chancellor to have no new measures and
no finance new finances associated with
the queen's speech to address that story
cost of living crisis
the start reality is the longer nothing
is done the more people plunge into fuel
and food poverty
the april 22 price cap is now 75
higher than just a year ago the national
energy action estimate that up to six
and a half million households could now
get into fuel poverty that underlines
why more action is needed for the
chancellor and we know that october
increases common could see up to 40
percent of households been fuel poor
now previously national energy action
estimated there's around 10 000
premature deaths a year arises from fuel
poverty
how many more premature deaths are
likely to occur with these increasing
fuel costs that's a reality it has such
an impact in people's lives that they
die early through living in fuel poverty
so how can any government minister
request of compassion stand by and do
nothing
now madam dave speaker even the british
chambers of commerce have asked for an
emergency budget companies like scottish
power are calling for one thousand
pounds of support and their energy bills
and yet the chancellor previously
insisted that taking measures now would
be silly why is he so out of touch with
reality and even what businesses are
telling us is required
now by the way dev speaker when we look
back to april 2020 in the onset of the
covert crisis the government did
increase universal credit one thousand
forty pounds to help people live but
back then home energy bills were seventy
five percent cheaper
petrol was fifty percent cheaper than it
is than now we've now dealing with food
inflation and general inflation rising
to 10 percent so if that 20 pounds a
week uplift was required to live two
years ago surely the chance we must
recognize that logic it needs to
reinstate that uplift and do so quickly
you even as the chairman tori pierce
stuart rose vaccine stating additional
20 pounds per week and uplifting
universal credits so it realized time
for the chance for the lesson
and madame dave speaker the reality is
that people in universal credit are also
those more likely in pre-payment meters
who are further penalized with a higher
energy tariff so these are the people
that are forced to self-disconnect this
winter as they simply will not have the
funds to put on the meter
they don't have a dilemma about whether
to turn the heating on or not they don't
have the choice
now yesterday i was at meeting with you
and mccall of the wise group
him and others within the wise group
deal with people who are in the front
line of fuel poverty and a survey of
nearly 300 people in glasgow 24 percent
were self-disconnecting are rationing
their heating there are real heart
rendering individual stories behind us
people relying on candles using hot
water bottles and juice living in misery
though the wise group like others
provide fantastic help and turn around
but they can only do so much other
groups as well at threshold trust do
fantastic food banks and they've
confirmed that even more people are
relying on their services
but rather an action madame dev speaker
we now also for the bizarre admission
from the b secretary that their nuclear
power policy is actually going to
increase our energy bills as economic
madness and unfortunate madness cheered
on and encouraged by labour
but it shouldn't come as a surprise that
new nuclear is going to add costs to our
bills an upper estimate of 63 billion
pounds for the capital and finance
course for one new nuclear station is
crazy to proceed when the cost of
renewable energy have ever fallen and
the so-called small modular reactors are
neither small
nor
northern cheap at circa
2 billion pounds per new station and
rolls royces don't want a contract for
one small water vapor they look for a
contract for 12 to 15. so what this
government should be doing is focusing
on providing cheaper dispatch energy and
agree a minimum electricity price for
the proposed pump storage hydro scheme
at cory glass the proposed extension at
kraken dam these can be delivered much
quicker than a fraction of the cost of
nuclear and indeed the 1.7 billion
pounds of chances used to buy a stake in
size we'll see would actually pay for
choreography about outright exactly and
madame dev speaker one obvious way to
reduce bills and emissions is the mass
of increased energy efficiency measures
the scottish government rightly treats
us our national infrastructure program
and spends four times more per capita
than the uk government on this the green
alliance estimate that retrofitting 11
million homes will actually reduce peak
heat demand by 40 percent but shamefully
instead of showing increased ambition uk
government haven't even brought forward
the regulations yet for equal four when
this is a program that's supposed to
start in the first of april and that's a
part of the nine billion pound package
the chancellor keeps bragging about
so what this government is doing is
trapping more children in poverty who
are therefore destined to have less
opportunities and less likely positive
outcomes in life
child
child poverty action group estimate
there's four million children poverty at
the moment and they say the legacy of
this queen's speech will be even more
children poverty but yet madame dead
speaker i stroke overnight the
chancellor could lift 250
250 000 children out of poverty by
scrapping the two child limit for
universal credit so when he knows he's
got the pirates disposal to take 250 000
children out of
poverty overnight why doesn't he act and
scar the car
why aren't they about touring about
ventures calling for the two child
limits uh
cap to be to be scrapped all together
what we do here are demands for tax cuts
tax cuts that we know in the
chancellor's promise are coming but tax
cuts will disproportionately help the
richest and not the poor
another decision to take this government
is not operating benefits even close to
inflation a conscious decision and as
others have said
blaming the i.t system is just a piece
of nonsense since chances are hiding
behind weak excuses
and there's something far wrong if the
government's i.t system is so poor they
can't press a button to increase our
perspective provide a percentage uplift
exactly
we're having one new policy announcement
of course madame dev speaker and that's
making 91 000 civil servants redundant
during this crisis now beggar's belief
when this government uses slogan making
work pay i want to start 91 000 people
and unfortunately
many other people who are working know
that work doesn't pay
people they are in work and in poverty
the numbers are increasing and again no
amount of blaster is going to change
that statistic now the government could
help
by making the the living wage the
equivalent of the real living wage that
is as thought would take more people out
of poverty and of course it wouldn't
actually cost the government any money
so why don't they do that yeah
and madame dead speaker
in terms of talk about balancing the
books of course another cohort the
government's balance of books on are
pensioners scrapping the triple law is
costing pensioners over 500 pounds a
year during this crisis
now as us as the chancellor if inflation
is running at 10 percent when the next
upright assessment is some undertaking
for pensions actually going to stand by
the place to reinstate the triple lock
or well they hatched one piece pensions
by 10 percent if that's what inflation
is telling us we're good if we could
confirm that
okay we'll just steer into space now
madame dev speaker the topic of pensions
also takes us to the mountains and lost
by wilmington uh women still awaiting
compensation now the recent phso report
highlighted that and confirmed that it's
clear administer my administration the
way the dwp delivered or failed to
deliver the news of the increased
pension is for millions of women so not
only will some form of conversation at
least be annoyed towards justice it
would put money in people's pockets at
this time we need now i met two
representatives from ursula spain friday
and they highlighted that fair
conversation airship about 150 million
pounds for 15 000 women money that would
then be spent local in services and
goods and a real form of leveling up and
even then much of that money would
return to the government in various
taxes
sadly by the end of this calendar year
over 220 000 women across the uk will
have died waiting for justice in the
seven years since the osprey campaign
began
thousands more women will die waiting
unless the dwp and treasury start
shutting down with campaigners to agree
now for fair fast compensation so again
i put it at the front bends how
acceptable is it to just sit back and
let people die instead of providing them
with justice and compensation they
deserve
now returning to the treasury and
helping to pay for support actually we
do agree with labor and the principle of
our windfall tax
however it shouldn't madam dev speaker
just by cash raid in the north sea but
rather a wider pandemic profit levy
tax justice uk has identified that just
six companies made an excess profit of
16 billion pounds in the financial year
2021 so clearly 10 additional leverage
on them would realize 1.6 billion pounds
for treasury
a much wider pandemic a profit level of
10 across the board would clearly raise
even more money now we don't remember
for doncaster north said that companies
shouldn't profit just from being there
in terms of circumstances so in that
principle i'd like to think he should
agree then that panda a sort of pandemic
profit levy makes more sense because
that's companies that benefit during the
co-recitation just by virtue of being
there and that madame dave speaker
should also target the companies they
made excessive profits through ppe
contracts awarded to them directly by
that government
if we return to the oil and gas
sector then there's no doubt that things
have moved
as john wilmer for doncaster said
the bp
chief executive has said that investment
won't be at risk and if you look at the
reality that shell and bp combined are
now in court to reach 40 billion pounds
of profits this year there must be some
loose change there for taken
but it's also interesting madame de
speaker that
in a sec it's interesting the tesco
chairman wants a windfall tax for oil
and gas so i'm sure he too will welcome
a windfall tax for tesco and other
companies that benefited during the
pandemic
i
genuinely thank the honourable member
for giving way and
and i think it's about two or three
short months since i was welcoming his
stance against labour's calls for a
winful tax but putting that aside on
on his quote of bernard looney does he
also is he also aware of bernard looney
the chief executive bp as well as saying
that the currently committed investments
would not be at risk from a windfall tax
he's also said that future investments
could be
he did
just fudge that at the end of the day
there's so much excess profit here that
something needs to be done we need a
serious conversation with us
interestingly in front of the beast
committee the chief executive centrica
spoke about the record profits are
making but the pay pay so much tax on
norway that's to pay much more tax in
norway than the attacks take here and he
confirmed that our attack attacks regime
can be balanced
he's quite happy paying more if it's a
stable regime so actually we could have
a serious debate about a tax regime here
that realizes more money for the
treasury especially in this time we need
now and that takes madame de speaker to
the treasury the chancellor himself has
generated his own one fall as our
enemy's bows have nearly doubled so is
the v80 intake to the treasury as petrol
prices are soared so the vat returns to
the treasury indeed the duty court he
was bragging about was actually long
paid for by the extra vat that was
already getting raked in and so we've
heard now there's a real risk that's
judica has actually been gouged out by
greedy petrol companies and not being
passed on to consumers so again that's
something chancellor needs to get a grip
of
oil and gas revenues have increased
between a half billion pounds in the
last couple of years and i've a funny
feeling that the autumn statement the
chancellor is going to predict even
greater income from oil and gas revenues
so that alone should be getting
recirculated and used to support people
madame debbie speaker
the scottish government are doing what
they can to mitigate the crisis but we
cannot make decisions a normal country
can make scottish government introduced
the game change and child payment
doubling it to 20 pounds per week and
that's going to increase to 25 pounds a
week earlier to this year
this could lift 50 000 children out of
relative poverty but cannot the same
positive impact that would otherwise due
to torah cuts
and this crisis demonstrates lack of
real options for scotland within the
current constitutional settlement we
cannot make decisions a normal country
can make it's not in our graft to change
vat and energy bills whatever the views
are in fog tax we cannot do that we
don't have control over fuel duty or vat
either we've limited warren powers we're
locked into bad decisions with the uk
government in terms of the race for
nuclear and kurdish labour money and
nuclear weapons taking out the eu and
been short changing funding from uk
government on that as a country we are
energy rich but we've got citizens
living in fuel poverty
we exported oil and gas for years but
don't even have an oil and gas fund
it's time for a different direction
madame dev speaker were for 315 years of
the so-called most successful union ever
but yet a government whose slogan is
level up and they know best if the
union's so successful we should need a
slogan about leveling up it's time for
independence time that we're able to
make decisions for ourselves
change the treasury select committee
mail strive
madam deputy speaker and i rise to very
much welcome this debate uh it does
indeed address one of the great
challenges
of our time the cost of living and of
course right at the center of that madam
deputy speaker lies the rate of
inflation which many members have
referenced in the debate
so far
and the responsibility for that of
course is with the bank of england and
it seems to me that in very recent times
the bank has come into a good deal of uh
criticism for not having apparently got
on top of that rate of inflation it's
currently above seven percent it will
rise to ten percent in the autumn uh
before falling back uh again next year
that's well detached of course from its
target of two uh so the question arises
is the bank of england culpable for
having missed that target to the extent
that it has been missed and uh i wanted
to speak today really partially at least
in defense of banging than one of our
most important uh independent
institutions uh in our country and to
make the following observations the
first as the chancellor has already
pointed out the level of inflation
across the world is elevated there are
some exceptions to that but most leading
economies are facing very high levels of
inflation in fact the united states
spain germany have high rates of
inflation than we do in the united
kingdom and our rate is broadly similar
to that across
the euro zone
the second point is what one can expect
from monetary policy under the current
circumstances and if you look at the
main drivers of inflation
those are a war in ukraine there are
surge in energy prices a surge in food
prices there's some of the effects of
the unlocking of the economy and it's
rapid growth and supply chain
bottlenecks that developed as a
consequence of that and then of course
what played out of the labor market as
the economy opened up and very few of
those factors madam deputy speaker are
amenable to being controlled through
interest rates and monetary policy and
of course monetary policy itself madam
deputy speaker takes time to take effect
if you put interest rates up it
typically takes around a year plus
through the transmission mechanism to
have an effect on demand and to start to
bear down on inflation so i would say
madame deputy speaker for probably about
80 percent of the rise that there has
been in inflation above that target of 2
we should not be holding the bank of
england particularly culpable for that
and those and some of them have been on
my side of the house who have as a
consequence of this high inflation been
calling the quest calling into question
the independence of the banking or
whether it should remain independent
going forward i think they are misplaced
notions and i think we should defend the
uh bank of england uh in that respect uh
very firmly there is one area perhaps
the other 20
of the growth in inflation where i think
the bank perhaps is at least partially
culpable and that is what has happened
in the labor market the bank was very
slow to establish the fact that the
market was getting overheated what
appeared to be isolated areas such as
amongst hgv drivers and other pools of
labor within the
labor market soon has spilled over into
a more general price increase
across labour and the danger here now is
a wage price spiral in which we see
wages chasing prices and in turn driving
up wages still further and there is a
real danger now that we're in a position
where future expectations of inflation
have become substantially de-anchored
from that two percent and that will be a
challenge looking to the more medium uh
and longer uh term but overall madam
deputy speaker i wanted to make this
contribution because i think it is
extremely important that when it comes
to the bank of england we have
confidence in that institution imperfect
though it is and even though it is
presiding over a situation in which
there are very high levels of price
increases i give way to the honourable
i'm very grateful to him for giving away
and i agree with him about the
independence of the bank of england at
the liaison committee in march the right
on the gentleman suggested to the prime
minister there should be a one-off up
rating of benefits given that inflation
is so much higher than the 3.1 percent
by which uh up rating was applied i
agree with him about that and i wonder
if he stands by that suggestion that he
made at that meeting i think the
honourable judgment very much indeed for
that intervention and i do indeed stand
by that i still believe that in a
relatively fiscally neutral manner that
would not across the period of the obr-4
cards require a fiscal loosening it is
possible to smooth the way in which
benefits are indexed and it seems to me
to be particularly regrettable that
these benefits universal credit for
example as we know tagged to 3.1
increase going back to what inflation
was in september we're now facing eight
nine 10 plus percent inflation there is
the possibility of smoothing that out so
that on the way up it becomes less
painful for people and some of it's
taken back as it all comes out in the
wash further on down the line so i'm
very happy to continue to work with the
honourable gentleman uh with that in
mind but perhaps that brings me on to
other fiscal measures that can be taken
in order to ease things for our
struggling constituents we've heard of
the windfall tax
in great detail today i would support
that and largely i have to say although
it wouldn't be quite as partisan the way
in which the uh right honourable
gentleman made his case earlier at the
dispatch spot i do think the arguments
that he has put forward are generally
sensible and i'm very pleased in turn
that my writing will friend the
chancellor has indicated that the door
is at least partially open albeit
caveated on the investment performance
of the companies uh concerned
and i also think um unlike the the
opposition that it's important actually
that we look at the size of the civil
service that we do
have an ambition to get the civil
service back in terms of size to where
it was in about 2016 before a number of
these different crises struck and we had
to gear up in terms of the numbers
involved a total of 3.5 billion
would be possible per year if we were to
do that which would be very useful
amount uh to have indeed i'm sorry
madame deputy speaker i completely run
out of time i had much to say as i know
many others will but thank you
um
i'm grateful and i'm pleased to follow
the uh the right gentleman who chairs
the treasury select committee much of
what he said um i agree with cost of
living rises affect everybody the
working pensions slack committee focuses
on families with the lowest incomes who
depend on social security and the
prospects for them at the moment are
very bleak
the committee argued unanimously cross
party
against the removal of the 20 pounds per
week uplift in universal credit last
october the government went ahead anyway
cutting the main benefit rate to the
lowest real terms level for over 30
years and actually as a proportion of
average earnings it's actually it's
lower now than when lloyd george
introduced unemployment benefit in 1911.
benefits are historically at a very low
level and no minister we've asked no
minister is able to justify that and
since then now we've had this massive
cost of living surge
citizens advice reports that a single
unemployed person spent fifteen percent
one five percent of their benefit on
energy bills two years ago
it's 25
now and it's going to be 50 percent just
on energy when the cap goes up again in
october how can people pay their other
bills which are also going up
national energy action told the select
committee that after last month's energy
price rises six and a half million uk
households are in fuel poverty it's a
disaster for families with long-term
health problems being cold at home
makes respiratory and circulatory
problems much worse
the gracious speech provided no help at
all to people dependent on benefits at
the liaison committee i asked the prime
minister why the spring statement did
nothing his answer was and i quote we
want to support people into work
wherever possible but a large number
cannot work they have to survive as well
surely government must now respond to
the immense pressure on those families
mike brewer of the resolution foundation
pointed out to our committee the obvious
problem with benefits going up by 3.1
percent as they did last month when
inflation is 8
and rising he proposed
revisiting up rating immediately for
universal credit as the chancellor has
confirmed he could do and as he did at
the beginning of the pandemic and then
in october for those benefits needing
longer and there are some as he's
pointed out to the house that must
surely now uh be be done universal
credit was raised by 20 pounds per week
uh before uh do it again and i very much
agree with what the chair of the
treasury select committee has just uh
said reaffirming what he pressed the
prime minister at the liaison committee
about
the the case for an interim up rating
the prime minister said he was going to
look at it it's urgent
uh crisis highlighted that uh that local
housing allows
rates have now been frozen for two years
in a row
average rents went up by eight point
three percent just in the last three
months of last year families on the
bread line face an average 372 pound
deficit between local housing allowance
and the cheapest rents in their area
in research just published lloyd's bank
foundation reports that 44
of universal credit recipients are
having money deducted averaging
78 pounds a month nearly a fifth of what
single over 25s can claim
deductions for advanced repayments uh
old tax credit overpayments energy or
rent arrears and the lloyds bank
foundation says this is quote driving
impoverishment and further debt
particularly amongst the most vulnerable
we need major changes madam deputy
speaker especially in the five-week wait
for a first regular universal credit
payment which forces people to take out
and advance and pensioner poverty is now
surging we know that in 2019 20
850 000 families entitled to pension
credit didn't claim it we need real
vigor behind raising uh take-up the
department should have a take-up target
for pension credit and a plan to uh
deliver it in 2010 11 dwp trials
automatic payments of pension credit uh
they should do that uh again madam
deputy speaker the least well-off in our
society need urgent help
as the john major
said yesterday people everyone needs to
believe the state cares about them too
there's no time to lose
thank you madam deputy speaker there is
much to welcome in the queen speech
program but i want to
firstly highlight a very serious concern
about
83 and 84 of the leveling up bill which
could massively erode local decision
making and planning
i hope ministers will think again about
rewarding themselves the power to
override local development management
policies which provide such important
protection against over development
but the main theme i want to cover today
is the broader economic theme and how we
ensure we have a sustainable way to help
people with the cost of living
and crucial to that is regulatory reform
envisaged by legislation such as the
brexit freedoms bill the financial
services and markets bill and the data
reform bill
as inflation returns to the global
economy at levels not seen for 30 years
it is imperative that we have a clear
long-term economic plan to grow the
economy raise living standards repair
the public finances after covered and
bring down taxes
this is the best and most sustainable
way to help people with rising household
bills
and of course like everyone else in the
chamber i know how urgent it is
that we help people with rising
household bills which is why
i very much welcome the chancellor's 22
billion pound intervention
raising the ni threshold is one of the
biggest personal tax cuts in decades
increasing the amount people can earn
before benefits are withdrawn has put a
thousand pounds in the pockets of low
income families
and of course the 5p fuel tax cut can
help everyone
but in addition to this we need a
convincing program to grow our economy
out of the traumas being inflicted on us
by the global rise in energy prices
that's why regulatory reform in the
queen's speech is crucial
i was one of the members of the task
force on innovation growth and
regulatory reform established by the
prime minister our report set out a
substantial list of regulatory
improvements to boost the economy and
create thousands of well-paid jobs
especially in high-tech sectors like
bioscience
this kind of reform only possible
because of brexit is one of the most
effective ways to grow our economy it's
the sustainable long-term way to ensure
we have the goldilocks combination of
sound public finances money to fund our
public services and lower taxes
put simply supply side reforms to set
enterprise and innovation free are the
means by which we can make the numbers
add up
we cannot spend our way out of an
inflation crisis we certainly shouldn't
borrow our way out of an inflation
crisis but we can grow our way out of
this inflation crisis
none of these reforms need to jeopardize
safety or consumer protection or the
environment
are set out in the tigar report we need
regulation which is more modern more
flexible more proportionate and more
targeted
new rules which are rooted in our common
law tradition which can be piloted and
tested and which can be amended if they
turn out to have unintended consequences
so that we deliver the regulatory
outcomes and high standards we want but
at a lower cost and with far less of a
burden on business and industry
regaining the right to make our own
decisions on regulation is one of the
key benefits of leaving the european
union for six years as a member of the
european parliament i saw it firsthand
how the eu legislative process works
it's slow it's cumbersome it gets so
bogged down in political horse trading
between countries that it's no wonder
that it often produces such poor results
i was one of just a handful of
conservatives to vote three times
against the first version of the
withdrawal agreement i did that because
i didn't want us locked forever in the
regulatory orbit of the eu
now we're free of that gravitational
pull
we must use the opportunities it gives
us otherwise all those years of brexit
rows and divisions will have been for
nothing
only when we have charted our own course
on regulation can we truly say we have
got brexit done
so now is the time to get on and do this
for our whole country too and that means
significant changes to the northern
ireland protocol now is the time to set
out a clear plan for growth which will
deliver high-wage jobs which will give
the opportunities and the lower taxes
which our constituents want to help them
with the cost of living and the
inflation crisis that we face in this
country and across the global economy
thank you name angela eagle
can we judge this queen's speech to be
successful in addressing the cost of
living crisis well mr deputy speaker the
governor of the bank of england
at the treasury select committee
yesterday warned of apocalyptic
uh situation uh with food supplies and
therefore with rising prices the bank of
england's monetary policy committee may
report warned that inflation would soon
reach
10 percent it also signaled lower growth
than previously predicted with an actual
contraction in quarter four of this year
and it expects higher unemployment too
and inflation it predicts will not
return to its target a few percent for
nearly three years the squeeze in what
the economists call real incomes which
take account of inflation is the most
ferocious we've seen in generations not
least because the rapid rise in
inflation is being driven by soaring
prices for necessities food
energy now these higher costs cannot be
avoided or easily minimized and it's
well known that they caused the most
hardship as my honorable right
honourable friend the member for east
ham pointed out in his effective speech
to the poorest who are the least able to
cope who have no savings and despite
what some government ministers seem to
think the poorest have little practical
possibility to increase their hours or
their pay at least in the short term
thus after 13 years of conservative rule
we see soaring poverty levels millions
relying on food banks just to get by and
the lowest level of benefits since lloyd
george was the prime minister
meaning that the social safety net
created to prevent destitution has been
deliberately shredded by this government
leaving many to cope with the
intensifying costs of the living square
cost of living squeeze without effective
help and we have a tory chancellor who
has said that it would be silly to avoid
any help and to add any help extra help
until the autumn against this background
the government's abject refusal to
alleviate suffering and use the powers
at their disposal to assist those in
real need is a disgraceful dereliction
of its duty its indifference to real
suffering will not be forgotten it will
be remembered as the hard times get even
tougher for millions of our fellow
citizens now labor has suggested a
one-off windfall tax on the huge
unearned profits currently flooding the
energy companies coffers and this would
help alleviate some of the suffering yet
the government refused to enact it
instead we have a hodgepodge of a queen
speech with 38 bills no focus and no
connection to the realities millions of
people in this country are facing it
shows just how out of touch they are
that this government prefers to press
ahead with new repressive laws against
noisy protests while ignoring the
collapse in law enforcement and
prosecution levels on their watch hoping
we'll forget the shamefully low numbers
of crimes which are currently prosecuted
and the even lower numbers which result
in actual convictions this government
which of that fraud run riot even as
they under resource and fragment any
serious police response to it while
millions of our fellow citizens fall
victims to scams and con merchants this
is a government which prefers to
campaign rather than govern it's a
government which thinks that policy
delivery is issuing a press release with
a weak prime minister who runs number 10
like he ran the spectator office as one
long chaotic back an alien irresponsible
party
and so we have today's threat to
legislate to tear up the northern
ireland protocol and down the
consequences for the good friday
agreement or our international
reputation as a country whose word can
be relied upon a country that respects
the rule of law this is the northern
ireland protocol which the prime
minister negotiated which he hailed as
an oven ready triumph which he asserted
in the 2019 general election got brexit
done
mr deputy speaker only this government
could be so irresponsible as to
contemplate starting a trade war with
the eu in the middle of the most
ferocious cost of living crisis in
generations no previous uk government
has ever regarded breaking international
treaties and breaking their own solemn
undertakings as a negotiating tactic and
sullying our international reputation in
the process and our country will rue the
day that this one did this is a
government that looks after its own
allowing a bonanza in dodgy covet
contracts for their mates passing laws
to wreck independent judicial oversight
and clamp down on protests the sooner it
is gone the better yeah
and uh welcome the opportunity to debate
this today in terms of what we can best
do to help all of our constituents who
are suffering here today
um inflation is running at seven percent
here seven point five percent europe 8.5
in america um the bank of england
governor has been clear that 80 of those
uh forces are outside of the
government's control and outside the
reach of monetary policy yeah so we much
must look to fiscal policy to do as much
as we can in a way that doesn't make the
problem worse by being inflationary
now turning first of all to the the
windfall taxes is what we're talking
about today i think it's important to
get the quantum uh in perspective
this is not a silver bullet it is worth
i think two billion pounds overall which
is about 72 pounds per household you
know if you target that at the lowest 25
we're talking about 280 pounds for
household helpful of course would it
solve the problem no
in terms of the design of it i have
three
concerns or questions uh in terms of
when we're thinking about whether we
employ it or not firstly in terms of
protecting consumers
is an unorthodox approach to suggest
that reducing prices in the sector is
best served by whacking attacks on the
producers
it is very difficult to see how this
would result in in prices being reduced
um in the sector now of course we have
the price cap which would help um in
some respects but it is without the
proper controls uh it is very difficult
to see how this wouldn't ultimately
be passed on to consumers
secondly in terms of um competition in
the market uh this is an industry which
we all know is very volatile uh the
profits for bp were a record low uh last
year they're you know an enormous high
now
um the uh right over member for
doncaster north was absolutely right
when he said that bp and shell have not
said that this is a you know a disaster
for them but in many ways they wouldn't
they're huge players in this market
actually they can absorb a windfall tax
the problem will be much more with the
smaller players the discouragement to
competition this might result in and i
strongly believe that the best way we
can drive down prices in this market is
by encouraging competition i think it is
really important that we've lost that
recently and i don't see how a wimpful
tax would actually encourage that to um
to get back in place again
and my last point about the windfall tax
is this um we need to be very clear in
this country that the best thing we can
do to help everyone is to drive up
economic growth
now economic growth in this country is
best served by businesses produ you know
creating jobs driving uh driving
consumption
if we are putting in place a windfall
tax on industries at random it will
discourage investment now i i don't say
that you know as a kind of as a point
about this you know individual projects
here and there and i i do recognize what
bp has said but overall as a business
environment we need to be extremely
clear of what our criteria are for
imposing windfall taxes or not and the
impact that they will therefore have on
investment and business overall in this
country because what we cannot do under
any circumstances is give up our
reputation for being a stable low
taxation economy
um so that aside there is um one idea
that i wanted to put forward to the
front bench of my own um
i think that we should introduce
something similar to what we have with a
water supply in this country where it is
illegal to disconnect the water supply i
think we should do the same thing for
energy um
following the privatization of water
supply in 1989 the act prohibited the
ability to disconnect water to supply to
domestic customers for reasons of
non-payment so companies can still take
people to court for the money's owed
but they can't cut off supply
i know there are some situations which
your energy supplier currently um cannot
dis connect over the winter months uh
for example if you live alone or with
other people who have reached the state
pension age
i propose that we extend this more
widely
um to make sure that in the very worst
circumstances we don't have situations
where people are are cut off from their
homes and i hope that that's something
that can be taken away and considered
but but more but more broadly i do think
we need to just think about when we are
talking about these things and how we
best help people let's think about the
the potential quantum for the winterfell
attacks what will raise the potential
harm it will cause and what the other
alternatives are
john cry
thank you mr deputy speaker i'll be
brief because i've got absolutely no
choice um
there are now i was going to say there
are now hundreds of thousands of people
lying awake at night worrying about
paying their bills that real figure is
probably into the millions now and it's
certainly the case in my constituency
i'm contacted by many people
day in day out or i bump into them at
various events or in the street who tell
me that they're worried sick about not
being able to pay
their bills and that kind of economic
insecurity and again i see this in my
constituency he's starting to travel up
the incan scale the reality is that the
um it's a bit of a cliche talking about
a choice between heating and eating but
the reason it's cliche is because it has
a great deal of truth in it
amongst poorer households
that choice between heating and eating
has been there for years going back to
the early days of austerity but that now
is traveling up the income scale and we
had comments which have been referred to
by my honorable friend yesterday by the
by the governor of the bank of england
who said i think the word he used was
apocalyptic
in terms and she was there
in terms of the
food price rises which are going to hit
this country and other countries to be
fair but certainly hit this country in
the next few months it's a stark figure
which i only discovered the other day
is that 12 years ago
the number of people using food banks
was less fewer than 30 000 that's now in
excess of two and a half million that's
gone from less than 30 000 to in excess
of two and a half million in only 12
years if there is no other figure which
illustrates what's happening in the
country now that should be sprayed on
people's eyeballs now it's more than two
and a half million people forced into
using food banks now this is an economic
situation without precedent certainly uh
in in in living memory
and
at times of national catastrophe
i would have hoped we would have learned
that full-scale government intervention
is
always the answer we should have we
should have learned that from covered it
was clear during curry that lesson has
not been learned that full-scale state
intervention when there are times of
national catastrophe is the only way to
respond to massive catastrophes of that
of that nature that has clearly not been
learned by the chancellor sadly he's not
in his place
now perhaps he's gone for a long lie
down to think about the advantages of no
i'm not giving way to think about the
advantages of a windfall tax and yet we
have a dedicated chancellor who's wedded
to the idea
that the free market will deliver all
the fact is it won't we shouldn't really
be surprised when we have a minister the
honorable and i use that word in his
broadest possible sense the honourable
member for redditch who said well if
you've got problems just work a few more
hours now we're sent here to represent
people not to attack them that's what
she said
very very clearly she attacked british
workers in the same vein a few years ago
some of the leading members of this
government this produced a book called
britannia unchained which some of us
might remember
which said in very clear terms quote the
british are amongst the worst idlers in
the world
we work along the lowest hours and we
retire early and it's just factually
incorrect
we work amongst the longest hours in
europe and we very often retire later
than people working in other european
countries that historic contempt
for british workers is what's behind the
let's say fair attitude to the current
catastrophe and if it doesn't change
quickly we are heading for catastrophe
yeah yeah
thank you mr deputy speaker
help helping our constituents with a
rising cost of living is clearly
the most pressing challenge facing our
country like most other countries in
western europe and north america over
the next year it was rightly right at
the top of
the queen's speech because it does need
to be right at the top of
the government's agenda for the year
ahead
prices are rising
right around the world we know that
there are a number of factors that have
come together some of them
have been uh
supply led with uh with some crucial
supplies still suffering the the impact
of the uh of the pandemic
whilst others uh are
demand-led uh pent up demand that is
being released
resulting in excess demand as people are
now making purchases that haven't been
possible over the past couple years as
well as the switch in many forms of
energy to
lower
uh carbon forms of fossil fuel fuel such
as moving away from
coal and other dirty fossil fuels to
cleaner
fuels such as
such as
gas
it it is all coming together to
to
cause
increases in prices that few of us have
uh have have uh seen in our adult uh
lifetime and so a large package of
support is clearly necessary and i
welcome the support that the chancellor
has already introduced and has already
announced and particularly the
strong focus on helping low-paid work
workers to help those most likely to be
to be struggling the increase in the
national living
wage
last month
uh the additional money through the
universal uh credit taper uh helping
uh
well over a million uh families by over
a thousand pounds and of course from
july the increase in the national
insurance threshold contribution
threshold that will add another 330
pounds into people's
uh in pay packets will mean that
together
the lowest paid workers are
significantly better off and of course
this is part of a 22 billion pound
package now 22 billion pounds are called
it it's an enormous number but i think
it's difficult to grasp quite how big a
number it is it is more than
the budget for
for example for police and for border
force combined these are not
insignificant
figures
and of course that's also on top of the
sums that were spent to help
get people through the pandemic paying
the wages of 12 million workers either
through furlough or through
self-employment
income support scheme but many of our
constituents are still struggling and as
prices continue to rise over the coming
months
even more
will struggle and so
more
will need to be done the government
needs to be constantly looking at
what can be done to be providing
effective and sustainable
support
i welcome the special cabinet meeting
last thursday and hope that this
uh will be part of a long
series of
reviews to look at the measures that
might be introduced and i would urge the
treasury other ministers to look at
how we can narrow that gap between when
cpi and earning growth figures are
calculated for operating both pensions
and
benefits
so far ahead of when those increases
come in in normal times the difference
between say september cpi figures in
april
might amount to half of one percent it
might amount to 50 60p a week on a
pension but at a time when this very
sharp increase is inflation it is
obviously
four five six seven pounds a week on
windfall tax i would normally oppose
retrospective taxation i do think that
the circumstances what uh we've seen
with energy markets doesn't mean that
this can be justified but we do need to
be confident as my honourable friend for
seven notes said that the benefits of
such attacks do outweigh the cost that
we have to understand what those costs
are and the benefits perhaps are not
quite as high as people imagine it
certainly wouldn't pay for the package
that the right honourable member the
former leader of the opposition
set out
it would probably be about 14 15 billion
pounds spare it would be about five
pounds per month a household instead of
the large amount of the government has
delivered
eagle thank you mr speaker i want to
begin by referring to something that i
care a lot about the talks have been in
the queen's speech but it wasn't the
hillsborough law and in particular the
public advocate bill that my noble
friend lord wills first introduced into
the other place in 2014 and that he and
i have been introducing into both houses
ever since its aim is to prevent
families to reap bipolar disasters from
ever again having to endure the horrors
that the hillsborough families and
survivors have endured over the course
of 33 years something similar was in the
conservative manifesto in 2017 but it's
disappeared and i don't understand why
disasters continue to happen and whilst
each has its own particular
circumstances there are common themes
which a public advocate proposed in my
bill would work to ameliorate at an
early stage saving years of heartache
pain and cost to those affected and
saving millions of pounds in costs to
the public purse i know that the right
honourable member for pontefractin
castleford mentioned it in her speech
and the right honourable member for
maidenhead who told the pm on the first
day of the debate that he should simply
adopt my bill well naturally i agree
with that
it would fulfill a manifesto promise and
why has it disappeared mr deputy speaker
i simply don't understand it
it's long since past due that the public
advocate will be enacted it's long past
due that the hillsborough lobby passed
through this place and i hope even now
the government decide to do it they'd
get a lot of support on this side of the
house mr dre speaker the last 12 tour
years have seen economic growth stagnate
it's fallen from two percent a year on
average under labor to just one and a
half percent and is forecast by the bank
of england to go negative shortly
inflation's hit seven percent is
forecast to reach 10 later this year
energy bills are up 54 this year already
and are going to rise further in october
food and fuel prices are soaring because
of the end of frictionless trade with
europe after brexit and because of the
shocks caused by the ukraine war and
coving coming food increases will be
apocalyptic according to the governor of
the bank of england yesterday yet the
obr says real wages would be lower in
2026 than they were in 2008 but before
the global financial crisis my
constituents have faced 12 years of
frozen wages and real terms cuts to the
support that they used to rely on in
difficult times the government have
recently cut universal credit by a
thousand pounds and have increased
benefit levels by three percent when
inflation is over seven percent of real
terms cut for some of the poorest in our
society the government have just
increased taxes on working people by
increasing national insurance one of 15
tory tax risers that have left taxes at
their highest level for 70 years the
government's failure to help the poorest
people now is exacerbating the cost of
living crisis faced by thousands of
families in garson and hail wood we need
measures to tackle the cost of living
crisis with an emergency budget to
impose a windfall tax on the oil and gas
companies uh coining it in because of
the soaring price of energy and we need
it now that is why i welcome very much
the amendment to the loyal address
tabled by the opposition from bench we
really do need short-term measures that
will help immediately when the bills
need paying not promises of jam tomorrow
sometime in the future when it will be
too late to averse avert serious crises
for many families in my constituencies
and and let me say to government
ministers and some tory back benches
that the old tory trick of blaming poor
people for their own misfortune as
though they are morally culpable is
heartless and it shows that they're out
of touch in addition to being callous
many of my constituents have been trying
to get more hours or better jobs buying
super cheaper supermarket brands cooking
on a shoestring and are still sinking
financially they simply don't have
enough money to live because of
increasing costs and real cuts in their
income that have gone on for years many
are disabled some can't work even though
they want to or change their
circumstances easily or they have caring
responsibilities and lose more in
additional child care costs by
increasing their hours than they gained
from increasing wages that they might
get for working for longer or their
pensioners on small fixed incomes
without the financial resilience to cope
with huge increases in the cost of
living many budget their incomes to
within pennies and it's not fair to
imply that they're themselves at fault
for their situation or they could easily
choose to change it if only they'd
bother to do so when this government
begins to realize the truth of this then
they might start to think that they
should do something about it mr deputy
speaker as energy bills rise by record
amounts later this year it's shameful
that the chancellor is not doing
anything really to stop it and he's more
intent on his own feud with the prime
minister about his own political future
than about the future of millions of
people in this country members opposite
could do some good they could vote for
this amendment tonight
marie morris
thank you
speaker
what do you mean by cost of living well
we really mean the cost of housing
utilities
we also mean food
now the argument has been put that all
of these are out of the control of the
government in one sense because they're
driven by international pressure well
housing actually is a domestic
competence
and i think my concern is that the
leveling up and regeneration bill has
missed an opportunity
certainly in my part of the southwest in
devon finding affordable housing is
where my impossible social housing
is is almost invisible because there is
nothing in the planning system which
actually ensures one that affordable
really means affordable there is no
regionalization of the term and two
because there is nothing to stop
ultimately the rgb between the developer
and the planning authorities which means
the
the sun set aside for affordable and
social effectively become uh tiny so
local government uh local authorities
need more power and they need to be able
to hold the line so we get the property
we need and that's affordable at not
what the developers want
but then of course we do have to deal
with those things which while not
generated by a domestic
drivers nonetheless are things that are
affecting every man and woman in the
street and we need to address them and
we need to provide the help and support
as the chancellor very effectively did
during covert
and the support which has already been
provided to the poorest in society is
very welcome but i sometimes think that
the treasury doesn't recognize that
everybody is hurting you only have to
look at the government's own ons
statistics to see that everybody needs
some support and it seems to me when you
look at pensioners on fixed incomes uh
when you look at those who've done the
right thing uh they have invested in a
home they can't just move home change
their mortgage change the solutions fire
they are struggling the same issue
trying to meet the costs of housing
utility and food bills
they need some help and i think
therefore when we're looking at
solutions we shouldn't reject solutions
just because they don't only impact and
benefit those who are the poorest
i'm not a great believer in increasing
tax i am a great believer in reducing it
and one way we can afford as i have said
on a number of occasions is to cut the
80 on energy bills now we are
renegotiating the ni
protocol now we are looking at talking
to brussels it cannot be right that the
vat
on residents across our united kingdom
cannot be under the control of the
government it seems to me
that would be a very sensible way
forward tinkering with second third
year mots rather than single year i
don't think really cut it
now that effectively is going to be a
windfall on the treasury and that to me
is the more appropriate than a windfall
on the
those that produce productivity and and
and generally growth in our country
however the government needs to make
ends meet and i think there needs to be
a thorough look at the various spending
commitments and the various projects
we'll talk about hs2 but that's only one
of many and there's so much vested
interest in all of those projects my
recommendation to government would be
you ask the national audit office to set
up a commission specifically to look at
what projects can we and should we cut
they may be nice but they are not
necessary
but there is one other area which we
haven't touched on which is causing a
lot of grief
we say rightly isn't it wonderful that
unemployment is at a low level but
there's a reason for that it's because
there's been a fundamental uh reshake uh
of the labor market a number have fallen
out in devon a number of people in their
40s and 50s are out of the market we've
got a 25 shortfall in that particular
age group something isn't working and
talking to my employers unless we fix it
we are not going to help them survive
and we need them to survive to be able
to carry on paying the wages
so again i think we need to look up
what's causing the problem i think there
are at least two things there will be
more
one is to do with our benefit system i
think the my honourable friend kachin
ferdinwood agree did a grand job and the
government has implemented much of it
but the market's changed it needs review
and it seems to me what's stopping
people is the challenge of losing
housing benefit in child care we've
addressed the tape to some extent but
there is more work and i would suggest
that the government asking
the the honorable member to set up a
task force to look at this but also look
at the whole structure of employment and
to look at how we attract people from
overseas to work uh in our markets the
gracious speech has much to commend it
but addressing cost of the living isn't
one of them
valerie vaz thank you mr deputy speaker
and it's a pleasure to follow my
honorable friend the member for newton
abbott
and it's sadness deputy speaker that our
gracious sovereign missed uh announcing
the government's program and we look
forward to seeing her again in the
future mr deputy speaker this is one of
the biggest crisis that is engulfing
people in our nations and regions that's
what people have said to us in the
recent local elections they are facing a
cost of living crisis from cumbria to
westminster
in april benefits and pensions rose by
3.1 percent and yet the rate of
inflation was 6.2 and is about to go up
tomorrow the government's own
independent physical watchdog the office
of budget responsibility said living
standards in 2223 are set to fall by the
largest amount in a single year since
records began in night in the 1950s and
the resolution foundation said the
income of an average household will be
cut by 1 200 this year that's the
background of life for our constituents
that the gracious speech contained
nothing that will help them
some are okay the oil and gas company
said we have more cash than we know what
to do with
and that's why a windfall tax is the
best way to deal with this crisis to get
to ease people out of this crisis as my
right on friend the member for doncaster
north eloquently set out this has been
costed it's not borrowing it will raise
two billion pounds and will give each
household 600 of those most in need as
well as an extension to the warm home
discount even businesses are suffering
from the energy increase in energy
prices it seems the government prefers
windfall donations to a windfall tax or
windfall fast-track contracts to their
friends a government minister says work
harder people and yet people have to
face more insecurity at work because
there were no measures to remove fire
and rehire a pernicious policy which
must end but this government is a
wasteful government it's not an
innovative government 8.7 billion pounds
wasted on ppe that was unusable passed
itself by date and overpriced a
government burning 45 million pounds of
ppe per month to get rid of it and the
contract for the waste company says 35
billion pounds 11.8 billion pounds lost
to fraud through the covid support
schemes just ask the minister lord agnew
who said it's a happy time to be a crook
and the chancellor's eat out to help out
71 million pounds wasted that warwick
university said accelerated the second
wave of the pandemic a government
minister leaving a note for civil
servants desks on civil servant telling
them to come back and then a week later
leaving a note to tell them he's got to
get going to get rid of them 90 000 of
them it may be a new gracious speech
it's the same old government
incompetence mr deputy speaker i want to
touch on two other points planning in
the gracious speech some proposals will
need to be looked at i welcome that the
government will enhance the green belt
but i'm not quite sure what they want to
do with the revised national planning
policy framework street votes putting
one neighbor against another but that
must be based on planning grounds but
what do you do with the council like
walsall council who despite 2 000
residents
not wanting an uh transit site
in clerk
the council went ahead against the
wishes of those people against the pla
site allocation document and against the
planning inspectors agreement to
continue to put it there in one of the
most dangerous places where walters own
assessment of acceptable nitrile
nitrogen dioxide levels were breached
people young children will be living on
that site and it costs 500 000 and yet
the council says they have no money for
allotments and tinkering with the human
rights act this is about a right to a
fair hearing to be represented and all
it does is enact the convention into uk
law to provide an effective remedy lord
bingham said every one of the convention
rights was breached in the second world
war just ask the people of ukraine that
they think there shouldn't be a human
rights act and the government must
remember there is the margin of
appreciation doctrine which allows um
our country unique legal and cultural
traditions to be
incorporated without flouting the
objective of the convention and they
cannot better the judge's ability to do
their job because they hear the evidence
i agree with the honourable member for
garcia and halewood about the public
advocate that will end the hurt the
people in grenfell tower or the horizon
post office or the bloody sunday or
hillsborough and remembering
hillsborough 27 years it took i want to
congratulate jurgen klopp
for winning a fantastic effort
mr deputy speaker our constituents are
faced
with an increase in mortgages fuel
prices
food prices energy costs all going up
osdor found that wages are now lower and
real terms than in 2008 our constituents
deserve better a safety net in bad times
but most of all opportunity and
prosperity
pleasure to uh listen to contribute to
my honourable friend the member for
warsaw south and to
to follow her and it's also
uh um
a pleasure to be able to welcome her
majesty's gracious speech introduced by
this prime minister
and this chancellor leading a government
which continue to look at finding
long-term solutions to
large persistent problems and having the
courage
to pursue those uh fully
the debate today is titled mr deputy
speaker as you know tackling short and
long term in the cost of living
increases and many of the contributions
have focused on some of the immediate
quite rightly the immediate pressures on
costing i want to just make mention a
couple of points that look at longer
term solutions if i if i may the first
really is an issue that came up on at
our
business and energy select committee
which is about the problem of
decarbonizing home heat if we wish to
achieve our net zero goals in the time
frame that we as a parliament has set
out one of the most significant
challenges is how a household is going
to afford a change in the way in which
they heat their homes to be consistent
with net zero the costs appear to be
about a twelve thousand pound upfront
cost which is well beyond the ability
and opportunity of any household to
afford essentially to replace something
which is working perfectly satisfactory
now for something that will work
hopefully perfectly satisfactorily but a
much less impact on the climate and uh
in our hearing that we had it was clear
there were no obvious solutions around
today that were going to solve that and
that led to significant debate in the
committee and i wanted to draw the front
bench's attention
to solutions around
the idea of net zero uh community green
schemes now in a previous contribution i
talked about the possibility of
attracting
enterprise eis scheme towards a net zero
scheme
but there are also ways to get patient
capital and pension fund capital in
and a group banks without boundaries has
been working with the city's commission
to look at green neighborhood funding
models
and that combines the opportunity to
retrofit housing by putting in the
insulation that many very poorly
insulated houses required together with
the installation of
heat pumps and other grounds on a
community basis and by the way
mississippi at the same time looking at
ways of making the step change in
recycling which this government is
trying to accomplish so that we can
really make a big step forward on the
circular economy and interestingly by
doing it on a community basis
you have two very significant
public gains first of all you create a
financial model that can attract pension
fund money in because it has a long-term
return and is at scale and secondly you
get over the inequities of saying that
individual households ought to be
providing the finance for achieving
their zero which means many poor
families many poor households will never
be able to make that leap forward and
thirdly by attracting in that private
capital it can substantially reduce the
cost to the treasury of achieving that
long-term gain it won't affect energy
bills in the short term but my goodness
that's the sort of idea that we need if
we are to try and find a pragmatic
rather than ideological solution to
achieving green energy change can i also
mention about regulatory change and echo
some of the comments that my right
honourable friend the member for
chipping barnet made
we do need substantial regulate
regulatory change in this country we
have too long uh even since uh our exit
from the u.s in too long sticking with
the sporadic regulatory powers of the of
the eu
making insufficient progress to get the
agility that my right honourable friend
made and we rely too much on regulatory
agencies in this country who i'm afraid
too frequently are showing that they're
asleep at the wheel we looked in the
past about the uh frc and the pensions
regulated with issues like bhs and
carillion it's nice to see an audit
reform bill in the queen speaking the
gracious speech but it's only in draft
we need to look at issues to do with off
gem offshore last year when earth was
off jack
a few last year where were they the year
before absolutely nowhere in our
committee mr mr speaker this is a
off-gem's job was to improve competition
we had someone he was at university
when asked do you have a finance
director he said i don't need one
when we asked him president did you have
one he said well i've got my dad
and he was responsible for 300 million
pounds of consumers expenditure on
energy
off gem asleep at the wheel frc and
strongly as deep in the world the
pension regulator steam the world the
bank of england potentially asleep at
the wheel let's have real substance in
reform of our regulatory agency to
ensure we have performance indicators
and oversight by this house and by the
public yeah
and the next two speakers will be five
minutes but then we're going down to
four minutes from then on vera hob house
speaker it was interesting to listen to
what uh the member for north east
bethlehem has to say about green
community energy funds
but mr deputy speaker a great deal is
missing from this year's queen's speech
nothing about making misogyny a hate
crime or tackling violence against women
and girls nothing about making housing
more affordable and once again the
climate emergency was not mentioned even
once thousands are struggling because of
the cost of living crisis
now is the time for the government to be
bold about the future of energy where it
comes from and what it will cost one of
my constituents told me i do not heat my
home properly and stay in bed to keep
warm i welcome the upcoming energy
security bill but will it say in no
uncertain terms that the future must be
renewable energy and not fossil fuels
will it set an end day for the uk to
stop extracting all fossil fuels and
leave gas and oil in the ground
where is the windfall tax on the super
profits of oil and gas giants that the
liberal democrats are calling for where
is the retrofitting program to save
energy and ease the
burden of rising bills
why are developers still able to build
homes which will need expensive
retrofitting in a few years time because
the government has so far failed to
introduce legislation to build net zero
homes now
unless we see a decisive legislative
program now households will struggle
with the cost of living crisis
far into the future
in birth and north somerset the average
household energy bill has risen to a
staggering 1 360 pounds research
suggests that the government's
short-sighted decision to scrap the zero
carbon homes policy has added nearly 400
pounds per year to people's energy bills
insulating our homes is not just about
getting to net zero it will protect the
british people from violent volatile
energy prices and rising bills
the sooner that the government gets on
with a meaningful and resourced plan to
improve the energy efficiency of our
homes the better
access mr deputy speaker to health
causing increased anxiety to my bath
constituents bathroom northeast somerset
has been named as one of the uk's 20
dental deserts we have only 44 dentists
per 100 000 people for many of my
constituents nhs dental treatment
remains a distant prospect one of my
constituents told me she was afraid to
eat in case she broke one of her
temporary feelings because anything more
permanent would cost private fees
we will face an exodus of dentists from
the nhs if the government does not act
and reforms the dentist contracts and
what about ambulance waiting times
people in the southwest are waiting
longer for ambulances and everywhere
anywhere else in the in england with
waiting times regularly exceeding
two hours
this crisis is driven by the crisis in
social care the iuh my local hospital
has at least 100 beds that are filled
with people who are medically fit to be
discharged but have no one to look after
them at home
it is essential um that a workforce
this is essentially a workforce crisis
in social care unless the government
understands how to make social care a
valued and well-paid career the crisis
will continue into the future and get
worse
and finally
where is the
the promised employment bill minister
have promised to enhance existing
redundancy protections for pregnant
women and new mothers since december
2019 as a direct response to the
equality and human rights commission's
landmark investigations into pregnancy
and maternity discrimination in the
workplace
this government has wasted six years
talking about pregnancy and maternity
discrimination at work but failed to do
anything to tackle it
mr deputy speaker since 2015 the
conservatives have been running this
country since then we have become poorer
more divided more unequal
and less able to face the big challenges
of the future you're here mr speech
speaker i'd like to draw my attention uh
your attention please to my register of
interest
as a
former global investment manager i am
very concerned at the moment about the
trajectory of the global economy and
unfortunately the uk i don't think is
going to escape
that i'm very concerned that the
inflation regime around the world has
changed quite substantially in the last
couple of months and i think the
deglobalization which will be one of the
impacts of
what's happened through the ukraine
crisis i think that that will be a
permanent feature and a permanent shift
and we need to take account of that and
be aware of what we can do as this house
to help people with the cost of living
in that environment
we know that the price of food is going
to go up
the the
price of fertilizer is going through the
roof because supply has been disrupted
to such an extent and i think we are in
danger of being complacent
about this and what change this is going
to bring about
i don't agree with the other side who as
ever are saying that tax and spend is
the way forward i think we need to look
at ways that we can uh help the bank of
england out it's not the bank of
england's fault that the only tool in
their toolbox is interest rates but the
reality is that unless we in this house
find ways of getting peoples of ex
experience of prices down now the bank
of
england like the federal reserve in
america will be faced with no choice but
to keep jacking up interest rates to the
point where demand is destroyed
recession is created very severe
recession may ensue and that is what is
incredibly bad for budgets and balancing
them so i i welcome what the front bench
has
tried to put forward through the queen's
speech and i think it's
fine as far as it goes i appreciate the
help that is there for people i i agree
with my honorable my rightful friend the
member for barnett that
focus on regulatory reform is
particularly welcome but the reality is
that unless we have radical fiscal
measures now to reduce prices now
as in a bill next week or the week after
i'm afraid things will be too late and
we will be tipped into very severe
recession later this year so i would
recommend that we look very urgently at
bringing forward measures to reduce vat
rates throughout the economy
to reduce fuel duty
to
in essence try to keep
that price level that otherwise is going
to go plus 10 plus 12 plus 15 we don't
really know unless we have a way of
trying to keep that right now to four or
five i think we will be in very serious
trouble as a country and the the people
that inflation hurts the most are the
people at the bottom end of the spectrum
so i would uh encourage trying to target
these sorts of reforms on those people
and make such price help available to
them i don't agree with the
to be honest i don't think our side of
politics has
focused enough on looking at what we can
do for those absolute prices
i think helping people out is great but
subsidizing higher prices just
perpetuates the problem and makes it
worse and i think we really have to look
very hard at some of these things i i
think yes we need to look at investment
i welcome what the chancellor said about
that i think energy investment is going
to be particularly important making sure
we invest in our domestic food
production uh so that we can get that
that really firing on all cylinders is i
think i think that i think we need to
focus on almost on a war footing
because i just think it is that serious
that we need to help people with these
prices and we need to get
our economy
moving and if we don't do this i i fear
that stagflation is what we will come up
against and that is very very damaging
to
people's house prices to
to everything in the end
so i think we really have to have a
massive focus on that
but and growth is the key i come back
again
i i do agree that we should try to limit
uh spending and look at ways of
administrative reform services reform i
welcome what is in there they talk about
reforming the civil service but at the
end of the day
budgets depend on economic growth more
than anything else for their tax revenue
increases over time and unless we take
action this day
i really fear that we will be in for a
very rude awakening and we cannot let
our constituents down
order everybody resumes this it so the
time limit is now four minutes and if
anybody can make their points in less
than four minutes you will be helping
some of your colleagues i do assure you
paul blomfield
thank you very much uh mr deputy speaker
and it's a pleasure to follow the
honourable member for yeovil and he made
some
important points about the need for
action now
recognizing the severity of the crisis
that we face
i spent yesterday morning at a crisis
meeting in a part of my constituency
where incomes are lowest and we were
looking at the way in which cost of
living
crisis we're facing was impacting on
people it was a meeting involving
voluntary sector energy advisors food
banks debt advisors schools housing
providers local councillors and more
and we talked about the very real
struggle that people are facing to feed
families and pay bills
the impact it was having on mental
health are people who'd previously just
been managing but couldn't see the way
in which that was going to continue
we talked about suicide attempts as a
consequence
um which we've been
been faced in the constituency
we talked about the exploit exploitation
of people's hardship by loan sharks
as a re-emerging problem
now we discussed the efforts of all of
those at the uh
meeting to try to
offset
some of the damage that those families
were facing
and it was extraordinary but time and
again everybody there said
what we're doing is not enough
the government need to act and there is
a lot that could be done
restoring the universal credit uplift a
meaningful increase to the household
support fund and of course a windfall
tax to camp energy bills with the
reduction of vat on energy bills
mr b speaker the prime minister knows
that it could be done last tuesday
he opened this debate by telling the
house that quote
we have the fiscal fire power to help
families up and down the country with
all the pressures that they face now
problem is they're not going to use it
shrugging the shoulders and saying and
the chancellor did it again today what
can the government do to solve these
problems
it's not true and they know it
other countries have acted
france has limited
energy bill increases to just four
percent this year to protect consumers
and businesses by taking seven billion
pounds out of edf's profits spain has
committed to cut connection fees and tax
excess profits on
new electricity supply contracts to
protect people from soaring prices
spending 16 billion pounds on support
germany has instigated a range of
measures including tax reliefs reduction
on fuel duties and monthly public
transport ticket of just nine euros to
also encourage the modal shift that we
need in the way that people move about
it's a matter of choice
but instead this government points to
growth as in the answer and growth
clearly is important but their record
shows
that they can't deliver it
in november 2019
before we knew the word coronavirus
growth was the slowest it had been in a
decade
our bounce back from the pandemic has
been slower than expected this year with
the with the brexit deal failing to
deliver for supply chains and the
government's failure to insulate from
the cost of living increase a christ
cosplaying crisis limiting spending and
productivity
either they don't understand the depth
of the pressures and comments like learn
to cook or work more hours perhaps
indicate they don't
or they simply don't care
let people sink or swim but the problem
is too many people will sink
the money is there as we know it the oil
and gas companies have it more than they
know what to do with one second what we
need
um is action now as the honourable
member from yogurt said we face an
unprecedented crisis in the cost of
living we need needed a gracious speech
that addressed it we need an emergency
budget the government can't sit on its
hands any longer
thomas the deputy speaker and i welcome
the opportunity to speak we've heard a
lot about this afternoon about price
right hikes in energy prices and these
are well documented and concerning
um but i welcome the third supercharging
of effort to boost homegrown clean
energy which will drive down costs take
out the volatility of energy markets and
also cut out carbon footprint so that's
welcome
but more must be done now to help those
changes will help in the future but
actually we need help in our homes as
now as we've heard but also we need to
make look very clear clearly at the use
of the standing charge which is the
daily charge on every household which
has gone to 50 p plus 150 pounds more um
straight on the bill
and i'm very concerned that these
standing times will never come down so
it's important it's raised here and that
we keep our eye closely on the use of
standing charges for energy companies
but we also know that food prices are
also on the rise but we're not seeing i
believe the same kind of supercharging
of government response in terms of
providing uh home-grown
food production or increasing homegoing
food production now that we've left the
eu the government has the power to
prioritize food production using money
already available through the elm scheme
to supercharge food production to make
sure that farmers have the confidence
and security and the funding they need
to produce the food we need surely if
there was ever a time to boost food
production in the uk it is now i know
from speaking to many people in food and
farming and fishing
that the sector is willing they will
step up they can increase production but
at the moment they're actually planning
to sow less they're planning to realise
and they're planning to fish less
because of their concerns about the cost
as we've heard of fertilizers and also
other costs to fuel etc and their energy
the government must look very closely at
how we can supercharge home-grown
food
production but the real squeeze we've
heard a little bit a little about this
afternoon is on household budgets
especially in in cornwall silly and this
is the cost of housing
rents in recent years have rocketed in
my constituency you can barely find a
house to run and if you do a three
bedroom house would be 1400 plus which
is a massive increase on maybe a year
ago house prices also in recent years
have rocketed in the southwest an action
is needed and is needed now i welcome
again the queen's speech includes the
leveling up and the regeneration bill
but this must respond to the challenges
particularly in coastal areas
in relation to housing existing homes
must be made more efficient this would
help the cost of energy as we heard from
the member from west ham new homes must
be protected for permanent residence
it's far more easier to get homes built
in rural areas like mine if the local
people know that it will meet a need
that they recognize the acute need of
housing
more must be done to safeguard the homes
people already live in
every week i meet families being turfed
out of their homes and their homes being
flipped for other uses landlords are not
entirely at fault for this as changes in
the tax system and the methodology
method
methodology for rates for energy
performance rating discourages them from
providing homes for local families
so i welcome the government's recent
commitment to change that methodology in
epcs but more must be done to make sure
that being a landlord or providing homes
people to live in
is something that's attractive and a
secure thing to do
it is vital that the government take
more decisive action to support home
ownership secure quality homes for
everyone who needs a home and drive down
the cost of these homes through good
energy efficient measures thank you mr
deputy thank you very much peter dowd
thank you mr speaker can i congratulate
liverpool fc as an everton supporter but
hope people will respect my wishes that
they don't tell them um
mr deputy speaker the
chancellor seems to be increasingly
touching and dignity very idea that he
should be expected to loosen the purse
strings and support people who are most
economically challenged but the scenario
we found ourselves in today
is the m-i-m-i-f mfi
m-i-i-m-f predicts the uk will have the
weakest growth and the highest inflation
than any other of the g7 in 2023 and
even before the pandemic we had weaker
growth and before the war we had weaker
growth growth
of the g7 we were less productive than
the germans the french the americans and
counterparts by a country mile and the
uk has ranked 24 out of 25 countries in
the oecd
for public sector investment in fact mr
speaker british employees work 38 days a
year more than the germans are expected
to work even harder and we're facing
even more
pain research by the debt collection
agency lowell has found after factoring
in emergency savings carry debt into
default claiming work later benefits the
use of payday loans and holding high
cost loans the emergency and emergency
credit my constituency the people of my
constituents are in the top 10
constituencies hardest affected by the
cost of living crisis this crisis can be
solved the chancellor can help to solve
it but he won't
he never tires of telling everybody that
the
diminishing number of listening to him
i've got to say that 410 billion pounds
has been spent on the pandemic in one
way or another we spend 1.3 trillion in
one way or another and bailing out the
banks so we can bail out 66 million
people and millions of people who are in
dire straits mr deputy speaker
and he's lectured us because we weren't
supportive of his budget well it was
hardly a budget there was nothing in it
to actually be supportive of
nothing whatsoever of any significance
there for too many for too many of our
constituents who are on the press and
preparation precipice of falling into
deeper poverty
the government's failure to tackle this
issue is absolutely deplorable
what we need is urgent action now today
in the next few days from the government
not in six months not in a year not next
year now to take action and i think if
the government won't listen to this side
of the house then listen to the public
members office who can't seriously
expect us that their constituents are
happy with the what the government have
been doing and the government's handling
of the crisis
mr deputy speaker at most
we're not much further than two years
away from the general election
and we like general elections in bootle
because we can send the message to the
tories they didn't in my old seat
saint jos will see they didn't put any
candidate up in the local elections
nobody put a candidate on the local
elections that labor because they know
labor are the only people there to
support them so my campaign between now
and then will remind my constituents not
that they actually need reminding that
and anyone who will listen for that
matter that the tories of the party of
high inflation high taxation low growth
low productivity low skills low wages
low investment and low aspiration and mr
deputy speaker that's just for starters
yeah yeah miriam kate
thank you mr deputy speaker prices have
indeed soared in recent months
driven by a number of global factors
such as covid and the war in ukraine
millions of people are finding it harder
to make ends meet so far the government
has provided 22 billion pounds of
support including the council tax rebate
a cut to fuel duty and the household
support front fund but the heartbreaking
stories we've heard in today's debate
for example those shared by the member
for sheffield central do show that we do
need to do more and i particularly think
that we should urgently review uh
universal credit rates but we must also
be mindful of the inflationary pressures
of pumping more borrowed money into the
economy and the long-term debt
implications for our children
and grandchildren
i welcome the bills announced in the
queen's speech that will tackle the cost
of living in the long term by addressing
some of the structural issues that have
caused prices to rise and wages to
stagnate i welcome the energy security
bill which will secure our energy supply
i welcome the school's bill and higher
education bill which will drive up
standards and offer a lifetime loan
entitlement so people can upskill at any
point in their lives but we should also
reconsider whether some of the 11
billion pound a year cost of higher
education could be redirected to
vocational and technical education to
meet skills demands
i welcome the procurement bill and
brexit freedom's bill and we must make
sure that this legislation provides
opportunities for british industry
especially the uk steel industry to win
public sector contracts
i support many of the planning reforms
laid out in the leveling up bill but we
must build far more homes to have an
impact on prices we should focus on
developing whole new towns and build
hundreds of thousands of social houses
restoring the hope of having a decent
home to young people
the bills laid out in the queen's speech
will do much to tackle the cost of
living in the long term growing the
economy tackling rising prices but the
elephant in the room is taxation the
biggest cost in many people's lives now
is the state with taxation levels at a
70-year high
many of us on these benches and our
constituents are deeply uncomfortable
with this level of taxation
but not so long ago when the welfare
state was born life expectancy was 65.
people started work at 15
few live long into retirement
the state was not required to pay for
child care or adult social care because
women and the wider community provided
it unpaid
now longer life expectancy many years
spent in education and retirement and
ever better healthcare have increased
probably permanently the cost of the
state so what can be done we might not
be able to reduce the overall tax burden
significantly though economic growth
improving our health strengthening our
social fabric will help
but we can reform our taxation system to
share the burden more fairly
our system of individual income taxation
takes no account of how many people each
income supports
so a single person earning the average
salary of 30 000 pounds a year is
obviously better off than a single
learner family of four where the earning
parents rate wage is also 30 000 pounds
this single person has only themselves
to support yet the family has to feed
clothe and heat four people but both pay
more or less the same amount of tax this
is an individualistic approach to
taxation and so to have the same
standard of living as a single person on
a wage of thirty thousand pounds a
family of four must earn seventy four
and a half thousand a year an
unachievable figure for many and it
makes us an outlier many other countries
france germany the u.s take into account
the number of people that income
supports and our system makes it very
hard for families to work their way out
of poverty discourages family stability
and it fails to recognize the important
contribution that parents make to
society so in conclusion mr speaker i do
welcome the bills introduced they will
tackle the cost of living in the long
term but we must be realistic about
taxation yes reduce it where possible
but prioritize reforms that gen that
tackle generational inequalities and put
children first
kate osbourne
thank you mr deputy speaker
the cost of living crisis provides the
biggest threat in a generation to the
living standards of the working class in
this country the removal of the energy
price cap has meant that bills have
risen
by up to 54
for millions of households in the uk
this has meant the highest real terms
energy price increase in living memory
with the worst fallen living standards
since the 1950s
shockingly the cost of living crisis is
having a disproportionate effect on
women and according to work done by the
shadow secretary of state for women
inequalities currently more than 7.5
million women are living in relative
proper
poverty that translates to almost a
quarter of all women across the uk
this tuc has said that the chancellor's
response to the cost of living crisis
has been woefully inadequate and that he
needs to call an emergency budget to get
pay rising
help families with soaring bills and
keep the economy moving and they are
absolutely right
this cost of living crisis is
underpinned by financial injustice and
unfairness a crisis where tory smoke and
mirrors cannot hide the truth whilst
people have had to choose between
heating and eating their homes whilst
paying crippling bills
against the backdrop of these cruel
choices
oil and gas companies have managed to
turn over record profits in the first
quarter of 2022 with shell recording
a record quarterly profit of 9.1 billion
dollars up from 6.3 billion at their
dollars of profits in the final three
months of 2021 and whilst bp has seen
its profits of the first quarter more
than double on the previous year to 6.2
billion
this cannot be right
i was proud to be elected on a manifesto
which committed to bringing energy
companies into public ownership which
would have regulated prices and
ultimately put the accountability of
people over profit this government
should have looked towards countries
such as france spain germany and use the
queen's speech as an opportunity to
implement a low percentage price cap on
energy prices and should have committed
to implementing a windfall tax
such calls for a windfall tax aren't
only supported by this side of the house
but also supported elsewhere including
by the tesco chairman john allen
rather than a legislative commitment if
the best this chancellor can provide is
a tacit threat to impose a windfall tax
on energy companies that is simply not
good enough
the increase in energy prices and the
responsibility of the terrifying cost of
living crisis stops at the government's
door and they have failed to use this
queen speech as an opportunity to
rebalance the financial burden in this
country and it is through their lack of
action that more people will suffer
mr deputy speaker as we emerge from this
pandemic people in this country are
enduring one of the worst cost of living
crisis is seen since post-war britain
but the simple fact is it doesn't have
to be like this and the government has a
duty to alleviate this crisis by making
corporations and those that can
contribute more
this queen's speech wasn't only an
opportunity to redress this balance but
it was incumbent on this government to
take action and they haven't this queen
speech put forward by this government
has no substance or willingness to
redress the balance of power in this
country and unless this government do
more i fear for the people that i
represent in the general constituency
and for the rest of the people within
the uk thank you aaron bell
thank you mr deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to follow the honourable lady
from jarrod there is much to welcome in
her majesty's gracious speech since i
only have four minutes i will be brief
about the other bills the school's bill
which i believe will raise standards
help every child fulfill their potential
in this country the energy security bill
which will tackle the long-term cost of
living increases we've seen the
disruption that oil prices can cause but
we can expand expand on our leadership
on offshore wind build new nuclear and
kickstart britain's hydrogen economy the
brexit freedoms bill making it easier to
amend and repeal outdated eu laws and
the leveling up and regeneration bill
giving new powers for communities to
drive local growth and regeneration and
that in newcastle underline will build
on the success we've already had from
both the future high speeds fund and the
town deal over 50 million pounds of
investment brought into our borough by a
very well-run council as i said earlier
they've already paid out 34 000
residents they're 150 pounds whereas so
many labour councils i mentioned some of
them earlier i forgot kirk please with
apologies to my friend from there have
not paid out their 150 pounds and all
the words from the opposition benches
about cost of living being very hollow
when their councils are not getting that
money into people's bank accounts when
there is a cost of living squeeze and no
doubt that is why newcastle underlined
council was returned earlier this month
with the first majority in our history
in newcastle underlined winning seats
from labour in historic labour places
such as crackley and silverdale and i'm
very proud of the achievements of that
council and of the leader simon tag
turning today to the uh cost of living
support many colleagues have said we are
right to target growth and investment in
the long term that is the solution to
raising standards in the long term but
we do need support right now because of
the high inflation that's been stoked
principally by the oil price and by
putin's war in ukraine so i welcome the
threshold rise in national insurance 30
million people will be better off 70
will be paying less even after the new
levy and i noticed on the uh literature
from the opposition they said they would
scrap the levy but now they're growing
back on that is that a spending
commitment we can have for the next
election that they'll they want to scrap
that level because that levy is going to
support the nhs and social care and if
labour wants to remove it they should
say so
we are we are increasing the warm homes
discount to 100 pounds extended
eligibility to three million people
doubling the household support fund to a
billion investing 200 million per annum
in continuing the holiday activity and
food programme and i'm very glad the
chancellor of exchequer also listened to
me and my honourable friend from harlot
on fuel duty that 5p cart in a
constituency like newcastle underlying
where so many reliant on cars is very
helpful and now we may yet need to do
more in energy that depends on where the
oil price goes and i know i'm sure the
chancellor if the oil price stays high
we'll do more when we come to the next
round of the energy price cap and on the
windfall tax i welcome what the
chancellor said today uh which means i
think that the amendment from the
opposition is unnecessary uh i i am
clear that i am clear that uh winfield
taxes are unwelcome but they are
sometimes the right answer and in
certain circumstances they may be and
i'm very glad to see the chance of not
ruling anything out we need to see
proper action from the oil and gas
companies and investing and if they
don't then i will then i will be happy
to support the chancellor if that's the
direction we take i realize it's a
cyclical industry but i think there is a
case to be made here
and finally i would press
i would press the chancellor to do more
about leveling up through the tax system
i would urge him to look again at
council tax that 150 pounds to bans a to
d was very well targeted at people it
wasn't just leveling up for
constituencies like mine where 92
percent of people are in those bands
it's leveling up for anyone in a house a
to d across the country
the uh council tax rates are based on
very out of date valuations now i know
no government has ever had the appetite
for evaluation but i think there must be
some scope for lowering the burden on
people in those lower bands and perhaps
increasing or adding some extra bands i
and j at the top and i'll put that to
the chancellor and
it is brave thank you very much uh thank
you very much from the opposition front
bench but
that is i think something we need to do
to level up in the tax system but more
than anything i'm glad to have the
chance of executing leading us through
these difficult times remember that had
the opposition back just had their way
we'd be led by the member for israelite
north and the member for hazen
harlington and we wouldn't be standing
up to putin we'd be excusing him
take along bailey
it's often said that a nation's
greatness is measured by how it treats
its most vulnerable well sadly we saw no
such measures of greatness in the
gracious speech as the child poverty
action group states it was a legislative
agenda that risks leaving increased
levels of child poverty currently at
almost 4 million and expected to rise
further as its only real legacy
so what were the government's priorities
if it wasn't helping those in need well
we saw ideological flights of fancy like
forcing through the privatisation of
channel 4 which doesn't cost the
taxpayer a penny and doesn't need to be
privatized or the british bill of rights
which is understood to be a backdoor
vehicle to undermine the human rights
act on workers rights there was no
employment rights bill despite years of
promises from the government but in its
place was the brexit freedoms bill which
many fear will cut safety regulation
environmental protection and workers
rights and people are right to be
worried because despite the government's
wall fluffy processations to the
contrary some of the secretaries of
state responsible for drafting this bill
actually wrote a book arguing that
britain needs to adopt a far-reaching
form of free market economics with fewer
employment rights
in the meantime our communities are
suffering through this cost of living
crisis but the government seems
blinkered to their despair they hiked
national insurance contributions for
working people they cut universal credit
and pensions by offering only a 3.1
increase when inflation is predicted to
reach 10
and they sit back as oil and gas
companies sit on record profits whilst
people struggle to pay their bills
it's clear to everyone even the cbi even
sir john major that the government must
issue an emergency budget
and this means increasing universal
credit legacy benefits and state
pensions in line with actual inflation
it means scrapping the punitive aspects
of the universal credit system such as
the five-week weight the two child limit
the benefits cap and no recourse to
public funds it means increasing the
minimum wage to a real living wage with
a pathway including business support
towards 15 pounds an hour and we need to
see a real terms public sector pay
increase and finally we need an
extension of the wall homes discount a
street by street national home
installation program and a windfall tax
on fossil fuel companies now remember as
greenpeace suggests the government could
increase the tax level on oil and gas
producer profits to 70 as an absolute
minimum which is simply in line with the
global average and it would generate an
additional 13.4 billion for the
exchequer that could be used to bring
down bills and invest in energy
efficiency
fundamentally however for the longer
term we've got to recognize that while
terrific global events do play a
significant factor in the cost of living
crisis it's structural issues in our
economy and energy system that have left
us the most vulnerable to global price
fluctuations
closing our main energy storage facility
in 2017 without replacing it was a
monumental error but worse still are the
long-term structural failures that
privatization of our energy market has
caused
it is undeniable that public ownership
is central to addressing the cost and
energy security crisis we face so at the
very least our communities deserve an
emergency budget before millions suffer
possibly the worst economic crisis they
will have ever seen in their lifetime
but at the best we need to reform our
economy and our energy system so that it
protects people from the crisis that
we're seeing today
mahindra thank you uh mr deputy speaker
it's an honor to speak on behalf on
this debate on her majesty's precious
speech there's three particular topics i
wish to cover in the limited time i've
got
the first is security then the economy
hopefully planning
as members will be aware i've got the
northwood native agents in my
constituency and it's a real privilege
to to host them
uh we've seen through the awful war in
ukraine and russia the importance of
global security
and i
welcome the movements of sweden and
finland in joining that global peace
organization
i would like to strongly associate
myself with the commitments as put
forward by this government to defend
democracy and freedom across the world
including continue to support the people
of ukraine
but as well as military might we also
need to think about
energy security and food security
i'm pleased to see further progress on
cheaper cleaner more secure energy here
in the uk building on our hugely
successful cop 26 presidency
as a
member parliament that represents a
constituency that's approximately 80
greenbelt
i'm really passionate about supporting
british farmers and actually encouraging
consumers throughout our great nation to
buy british where possible
in terms of the economy
our primary focus as conservative party
should be on growing and strengthening
the economy just as it always been and
just as we always have
but particularly now as a means to ease
in the cost of living
our stated aim in the queen's speech to
grow our economy by taking a responsible
approach to public finances
supporting people into work reducing
public debt and most importantly by
cutting taxes is the correct way in my
opinion to manage our economy
and i know my wife and friend the
chancellor is looking forward to doing
all of that before the next general
election
measures set out in this queen's speech
demonstrate our continued commitment to
driving our economy forward while
tackling the cost of living
protecting british businesses and
investing in a modern
cleaner greener society
britain has always been a global country
and i know my vital friendly secretary
of state for international trade will
continue to secure further deals to
boost our economy and benefit our
society now that we have the freedom to
do so outside of the eu
in terms of planning it's a topic
specific that's very
important to my constituents
the leveling up and regeneration bill as
proposed in the queen's speech i think
is a really interesting point a piece of
legislation
i've spoken many times in this place of
how beautiful my constituency is
and as someone that as i said has a
constituency that's approximately 80
greenbelt balancing the preservation of
this undoubted natural beauty with the
importance of helping families and young
people to own their own home is a
crucial issue
one of the great many pleasures about
meeting my constituents is hearing the
passion and love they have their own
area
and the strong desire they have to
protect the character
i know the proposed bill will help
with that going forward
of course i will i thank my honourable
friend for giving win and i think one of
the points he's making is that it's so
important that actually um with
brownfield land we do make sure that we
utilize it back to the maximum with
housing etcetera but also does he agree
with me that it's important that local
people have their say on the designs of
their area and what goes where
i absolutely agree with that and i feel
like my honorable friend has been
looking over my shoulder because that
was exactly the point i was going to go
to next in my speech
introducing a bill for local growth
giving further powers to local leaders
to regenerate their own area and
reforming our planning system to give
residents greater involvement in local
development are all positive steps in
this
however
we must ensure that any local devolution
from this house on this issue also comes
with accountability where necessary
part of my constituency is represented
by the liberal democrat three rose
district council and it's disappointing
that there's been continual delays in
the local planning process
it's unacceptable especially when they
continue to blame both government and
the independent planning inspector for
what i regard as issues that they should
be
primarily dealing with themselves
local people should absolutely play a
bigger role in deciding how to best
improve and expand their local area and
we must be tough on local councils who
seek to play party politics and pass on
all the blame for decisions they are
taking
in winding up mr deputy speaker i
realize i've taken enough time in this
chamber but i wish to close
by saying that i welcome the measures
introduced in this queen's speech
particularly those affecting security
both of ourselves and our friends and
allies
the economy which we must continue to
grow sustainability
and with as little taxation and spending
as possible and in planning which we
will allow to give us local people more
of a voice in protecting their
communities thank you henry thank you mr
deputy speaker since i was first elected
in 2015 i've seen things go from bad to
worse for struggling people for families
um under the tories in this chamber
the the fact is i used to use the
expression that
should not have to make the choice
between heating and eating what i didn't
expect was for the tories to actually
even take away that option from people
because we now heard today that people
are self-disconnecting from gas and
electricity people are storing food
outside the refrigerator in order to
save money by switching it off in
dangerous circumstances
this is a dreadful time for people and
they're facing dreadful conditions
they're unable to wash clothes wash
themselves use cookers or even switch on
the lights
people are struggling they're seeing
energy companies put up their bills
sometimes increasing direct debits by
hundreds of pounds per month even though
there's little evidence that that's
required
all this is happening and yet this
government and a complacent off gem are
doing next to nothing
they should be doing everything in their
power mr deputy speaker yet their
inaction can only lead to the conclusion
that they just don't care they ought to
step in to help off gas grid customers
and businesses why because they face an
even heavier burden unregulated lpg and
heating oil prices are rocketing they
face cost rises of three to four times
of that of that from everyone else is
facing businesses off-grid are hammered
as are small and medium-sized businesses
in general who have no cap to protect
them what is the point in having a
regulator that won't regulate and a
government lost in their own rhetoric
this is a time when my constituents are
noting noting a 20 pounds per week
increase in their weekly shop another 80
pounds a month families can ill afford
was it lunacy that this government
knowing that people were facing rising
inflation rocketing energy prices moved
to cut the 20 pounds per week from
universal credit or was it ideological
cruelty yeah i'll leave that to others
to decide in scotland the scottish
government has already been mitigating
the imposed or the opposed costs and
families spending 350 million pounds to
nullify the bedroom tax as we heard
earlier from honourable friend from
kamalik and loudon spending four times
as much or rather four times per head on
insulating houses and properties and
when the uk government took away 20
pounds a week from families the scottish
government gave them the scottish child
payment of 20 pounds a week soon to rise
to 25 pounds providing real help through
very limited powers but what does this
chancellor do
a tiny council tax cut and a payday loan
as the honourable member from sheffield
central said earlier they do have
choices norway for example an
independent country similar in size to
scotland in terms of resources will
reimburse households for 80 percent of
all of their electricity costs above an
affordability level why isn't this uk
government using its powers reserved to
this place to take meaningful action it
just doesn't care scotland is at the
moment stuck with the bad choices that
this place makes the people of scotland
can now see even more clearly that when
the powers lie in scotland their
government their scottish government
will make the choices to protect and
support them what a contrast to this
place there is a hope however they can
see that the change our people our
families our communities need is coming
the powers of a normal independent
country are needed more than ever and
they're coming soon mr deputy speaker
andrew barry thank you very much uh mr
speaker it's a pleasure to rise to speak
in this debate and actually supposed to
rise last on the uh conservative benches
to speak uh because it has given me the
opportunity to listen to the entire
debate and what an interesting debate it
has been we've heard the liberal
democrat position is to leave all oil
and gas in the ground which makes for a
very interesting debate as to how we
actually develop our hydrogen-based
economy if all the gas is going to be
left in the ground we heard the snp
labour's plans for a smash and grab raid
on one of scotland's most successful
industries the couch they couched it
they carried ambiguous terms but the
people of aberdeen share and the
northeast of scotland heard them loud
and clear and we heard the former leader
of the opposition giving frankly making
frankly offensive remarks i would say
about uh the oil and gas industry in his
uh opening speech because the former
leader of the opposition the rightful
member for doncaster north stood at the
dispatch box and describe profits being
made by the oil and gas companies as
unearned
unearned i ask him to come up to my
constituency of west aberdeen cherokee
card and actually say that to the men
and women who go off to in the north sea
for weeks at a time in difficult and
sometimes dangerous circumstances to
provide the energy that keeps the light
on in this place and around the country
and tell them the profits that they're
the companies they work for are unearned
the right honourable gentleman also
referred to former governments uh
favorable being favorable to introducing
a windfall tax and he is right former
labor and conservative governments and
chancellors and prime ministers have
introduced windfall taxes and you know
what happened in every single to every
single time they introduced the windfall
tax investment in north sea went down it
is a funny plan to support working
people by putting the very jobs they
rely on at risk but that's what this
labour plan would do the former leader
of the opposition was also selectively
quoting mr bernard looney of bp he said
that no current plans to invest would be
affected by windfall attacks pd has also
made clear that future plans may be
affected and they all and the former
leader of the opposition
mocked the idea that over the last eight
years the uk's oil and gas sector has
been struggling does he not remember the
oil price crash of 2015 when a barrel of
oil went from 107 a barrel to 44 dollars
a barrel in just seven months is the
labour party so out of touch these days
with scotland that they didn't know the
effect that this had on the northeast of
scotland's economy probably because it
was under his leadership that's got the
labour party lost all but one of their
scottish labour mps the labour party is
also
rhetoric on tax if you listen to it
today you would suspect that the oil and
gas sector was paying no tax whatsoever
but in fact the oil and gas companies
pay three separate profit-based taxes on
oil and gas production corporation
corporation tax and a supplementary
charge and having for years paid on top
of that are further petroleum tax the
industry is the most taxed in the
country the office for budget
responsibility forecasted the upstream
sector will pay 18.5 billion pounds of
production taxes between 2021 and 2025
and a total of 23.4 billion through to
2027. this is 13 billion pounds higher
than the previous forecast in october
2021 the physician are confusing their
facts with their own spin bp did not say
that taxation has no effect on their
investment they were clear as have
others been that further investment
would be hampered by higher taxation and
they talk about the industry as if it's
just bp and shell it tells of a total
ignorance of an industry of all the
others whose fields are in the north sea
and whose follow years follow that of
the majors it forgets the supply chain
of small trade across the northeast
trade that ties us to the continent and
our nordic friends of the students
taught and discoveries made by
researching oil to create the green
future that we all calling for and rely
on the industry for answers it is good
that the chancellor is keeping all
options on the table of course we want
to see investment in green technologies
as we move forward but this labor plan
today is back of the [ __ ] packet stuff
high on rhetoric low on substance
typical same old labor yeah carla
lockhart
across the house we are all acutely
aware of the challenges the fair
constituents at this time
the grocery budget
puts less in the supermarket basket than
it did a year ago the electricity or gas
top-up card doesn't last as long as it
did a year ago
twenty pound of diesel doesn't take your
car as far as it did a year ago and of
course these additional household cost
pressures exist in a context where many
people have just experienced real terms
cuts to their income and or their
benefits furthermore it is not that long
ago
that the 20-pound uplift to universal
credit was withdrawn by this government
despite the appeals from these benches
and from charities the length and
breadth of the uk for the squeeze middle
child care costs continue to increase
mortgage costs face steep rises the
reality for so many is that wages are
failing to keep up with the increase in
the cost of living the national
insurance hike and the cumulative impact
of all these pressures has resulted in a
situation where households will see
their disposable income shrink the bite
is being felt mr deputy speaker it ought
to be of great concern to the government
that the obr has warned that uk
residents face the biggest living
standards drop on record that is why mr
deputy speaker it was deeply
disappointing and distressing for those
feeling this ways that whilst we were
told the government's priority is to
help ease the cost of living for family
families in reality nothing is being
done to deliver on that priority right
now the government announced 38 bills
last week many with great merit yet
nothing to address the immediate
pressures facing households and families
across this united kingdom a windfall
tax on energy companies enjoying soaring
profits was absent the opportunity to
cut taxes or reserves the inexplicable
national insurance rise was missed the
government repeatedly tells us that they
are a party of low taxes surely now is
the time to prove it and mr deputy
speaker for those in northern ireland
the opportunity is uh to give a clear
legislative commitment to address the
northern ireland protocol was also
absent the protocol exacerbates the cost
of living crisis in northern ireland to
simply bring goods to northern ireland
has increased and cost by around 27
according to our haulage industry a cost
being passed on to businesses and
consumers indeed mr deputy speaker the
the prime minister himself has argued
that the protocol is restricting his
ability to help with our post-covert
recovery and holding back economic
growth the prime minister is right in
this regard and as was so eloquently
outlined by the honourable member for
newton abbot uh the new uk wide vat cut
on renewable energy products cannot be
implemented in northern ireland because
of the terms of the protocol this is a
wholly unacceptable situation
mr deputy speaker and one that no prime
minister or government of this united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland can stand over the prime
minister knows what he must do today's
statement is welcome from the foreign
secretary
but we must see action and i regret that
thus far the chancellor has has been an
absent chancellor when it comes to
visiting northern ireland and i would
again extend the invite to the
chancellor to come to northern ireland
and hear from my constituents and
businesses who are failing the squeeze
in conclusion the long-term objectives
identified by the government around
higher wages more highly skilled jobs
and the move towards our own cheaper
cleaner own energy supply are very
welcome but the issue here is that
families cannot wait for these
objectives to become reality for many
the pressure is being acutely felt now
they need action now
hi lynch thank you very much mr deputy
speaker in the time that i have our
focus on two particular groups who've
been in touch with me in relation to the
cost of living
crisis many colleagues have already
outlined the scale of the problem facing
the country the latest bank of england
forecast suggests inflation will peak at
10.2 percent in the fourth quarter of
2022.
alongside this domestic gas prices have
increased by 28
and electricity prices by 19
the obr expects household incomes will
begin to recover until the second half
of 2024
the devastating combination of increases
amounts to such a battering on household
incomes that the resolution foundation
estimates that an extra 1.3 million
people will fall into absolute poverty
in 2023 including half a million
children
now there's one group in particular who
now felt particularly vulnerable to the
increase in cost and that's those living
with disabilities and families caring
for loved ones with disabilities i want
to pay tribute to one of my constituents
nadia clarke and her mum katie who both
inspirational and tireless campaigners
nadia had to spend months challenging
her care payments when they went up from
15 pounds to 68 pounds per week nadia is
not alone and too many are having to
make substantial contributions to
finance the essential care they need in
addition to price increases across the
board the latest data from the citizens
advice bureau tells us that 60 of those
who contacted them with fuel poverty
concerns in 2021 were disabled people
research undertaken by charity scope
demonstrated the extra cost faced by
disabled people at up to 583 pounds a
month on average stating the energy for
power and essential equipment such as
hoists beds breathing equipment powered
chairs and monitors was already
expensive
they stressed that these are not
optional extras that can be cut back
this is vital often life-saving
equipment
in an online video that nadia shared she
says it's not acceptable for disabled
people to be forced to pay care charges
and choose between the support they need
and food on the table and she's
absolutely right
similarly last week i was contacted by a
gentleman raising concerns for
sister-in-law who lives in halifax she's
on oxygen for 16 hours every day her
husband is a main carer but he is also
recovering from cancer
faced with unavoidable additional
electricity bills and heating costs
they're feeling desperate about their
situation
thankfully they've been able to arrive
at an arrangement with the company that
supplies the oxygen in relation to their
their electricity bill but it's just one
more example of how the cost of living
is proven unbearable for those who have
additional needs
now coming from a policing family mr
deputy speaker i've often saw in my time
here to be an advocate for the men and
women on the front line of keeping our
communities safe however to hear just
how badly the cost of living crisis is
impacting those even working in our
emergency services and on our front line
feels all the more shameful when you
consider what we ask of them
a recent survey undertaken by the police
federation of its members in my area of
west yorkshire revealed that 43 of
respondents reported worrying about
their personal finances every day or
almost every day 12 reported never or
almost never having enough money to
cover all of their essentials
and chief superintendent recently told
me that she had increasingly seen pcs
and new recruits in particular having to
seek permission to work second jobs on
their rest days including one euro crew
on a starting salary who had sought
permission to work as a carer
it's perhaps no surprise that the survey
also revealed that 94 of the respondents
said they do not feel respected by
government
government must do better
the windfall tax will be straightforward
fair and appropriate intervention for
this government to undertake bp and
shell alone are on cost to make a
combined profit of almost 40 billion
this year and there is widespread public
support for a windfall tax even the
conservative chair of the treasury
committee said that these are super nice
caroline lucas thank you very much mr
speaker we're in the grip of multiple
crises a cost of living scandal that is
pushing millions of households into fuel
and food poverty a war in ukraine with
disastrous consequences and the
accelerating climate and nature
emergencies in the very short time i
have i want to outline their common
roots in our fossil fuel-based energy
systems but first of all this cost of
living crisis is the most visible part
of what's actually a deeply entrenched
social crisis
one that this government has
systematically not only ignored but
actively exacerbated even now we get the
ignorance and arrogance of tory mps
lecturing about value brands and
learning to cook properly i do wonder
sometimes what planet they are on in the
sixth richest country in the world last
month over two million adults didn't eat
for a whole day because they couldn't
afford to get access to food that isn't
just a crisis that's a scandal yeah the
international price of energy and fuel a
global pandemic the war in ukraine
disruption to supply chains all of these
are factors and what's happening to
inflation and the cost of living as is
brexit but make no mistake the
associated social scandal is a direct
result of this government's political
choices choices which include cutting
universal credit and refusing to upgrade
benefits in line with inflation
the choices locking us into fossil fuel
reliance and climate catastrophe are
equally unforgivable companies like bp
and shell gambling on ministers failing
to rein in their deadly plans for more
oil and gas production
deadly because as the iea has warned
very clearly there can be no new fossil
fuel exploration and development if
we're to keep global heating below the
1.5 degree threshold yet we know fossil
fuel giants are investing in giant
carbon bombs that will accelerate
climate breakdown with the consequences
felt heavily by the poorest and most
vulnerable this is nothing less than
criminal the government's choices have
consequences for the war in ukraine too
for putin's war trust so i welcome the
consensus that we must stop financing
his war crimes and that we need to stop
importing russian oil and gas what i
cannot welcome is that for years
policies that could have brought us to a
place of energy resilience have
recklessly been torn up with uk energy
bills nearly 2.5 billion higher as a
result all that this government is about
to deliver an unambitious under-financed
energy strategy that will leave millions
in poverty and accelerate the climate
crisis while doing nothing to reduce the
uk's dependence on russian oil and gas
so here are five policies to help us
rise to the challenge first a street by
street local authority-led retrofit
revolution as the cheapest fastest most
effective way to cut household bills
reduce demand cut climate emissions and
create thousands of jobs in the process
second a transition to the abundant
homegrown renewables which our nations
are blessed with renewables that are
already cost competitive with onshore
wind six times cheaper than gas then of
course the dirty profits windfall tax on
the obscene profits of the energy giants
but it shouldn't stop there instead it
should pave the way for a carbon tax
levered on every tonne of co2 released
this critical level would help shift us
fairly towards a clean green economy
contributing to free home insulation for
those who need it free public transport
and a universal basic income fourth no
more subsidizing fossil fuels the uk has
one of the most lacked regimes in the
world for the oil and gas sector in 2019
companies got away with paying 12 and a
half times less tax for a barrel of oil
produced here than in norway for example
in 2020 shell effectively paid no tax in
the uk at all the only country where it
operates where that was the case so why
doesn't this gracious speech include
legislative proposals to kick these
climate criminals out of britain for
good tell shell it's not welcome to
relocate its headquarters to london laws
that would see those energy bosses who
commit crimes against humanity by
continuing to plan vast oil and gas
projects that would shatter the 1.5
climate goal they are the ones who
should be put on trial not the peaceful
protesters who are now defending our
futures finally no new oil gas or coal
licenses every penny spent pumping oil
from the north sea is making the future
less livable that is absolutely
unacceptable it is criminal and it has
to stop jeff smith
thank you it's a pleasure to follow the
honourable lady and i agreed with much
of what she said mr deputy speaker this
is a queen speech from a government with
the wrong priorities and running out of
ideas our constituents are struggling to
get by let alone live well and the
government's response to this has been a
parade of out of touch and frankly
insulting ministerial media appearances
and a huge gap where there should be a
strategy to tackle the cost of living as
many have said already and not just in
this chamber today but in business as
well we need an emergency budget to
bring in immediate help for struggling
families in manchester worthington and
across the country we need that windfall
tax on gas and oil profits and i'm
looking forward to voting for it tonight
we've had warm words from a number of
people in the opposite ventures and they
can join us they can come make a
difference tonight but to give real real
help to a time of crisis people who need
it
um
there are some other important measures
that aren't in the queen speech it's
really disappointing that we've got only
draft proposals and not a pill on um the
family review of football governance
we've been calling for the
recommendations for especially an
independent regulator for a long time
and the government in fairness have said
that we'll do it but they've kicked it
into the long grass and this is really
urgent for the future of our national
game berries already collapsed darby and
oldham
have struggled and we've seen in the
media the potential for more clubs
across the country to be
on the brink under the new government's
new timetable a regulator wouldn't be in
place until at least 2024 and by then
for many clubs it could be too late i
think it could well be
much longer than that we've already had
extensive research consultation engaging
with fans engaging with stakeholders we
need to get on with it football clubs
are at the heart of our communities and
we we need to we need a governance
system that suits that
i want to talk briefly on mental health
a quarter of mental health beds have
been cut right now 1.6 million people
are waiting for mental health treatment
we know the pandemics made the situation
worse depression doubled crisis
referrals up by 15
including among under 18 so it's so it's
welcome that the queen's speech did
commit to overhauling the mental health
act and bring forward the long-awaited
mental health bill alone again only in
draft the action's overdue i welcome the
government has accepted the
recommendations of simon wesley's
independent review but alongside review
for reform of the mental health act
we've got to see real action on early
intervention to reduce the number of
people becoming unwell in the first
place and to ensure those struggling can
access help early and we need a proper
workforce plan as labour have promised
um after three years and many promises
where is the employment bill
it's really it's really disappointing
that you know that this this could be
this could have addressed statutory sick
paid flexible working the rights of
people employed and precarious for
employment and and
just on that
there's a number of people young people
very often very often a minimum wage in
the nighttime economy
and there's a very specific measure that
the government promised and and could
have brought in but haven't which is
letting them keep their own tips you
know lots of bombers bars and
restaurants have good employees but some
of them
had a discretion in charge and then keep
part of the service charges and the
government promised to sort this problem
out and haven't done it that should have
been part of the employment bill that we
we should have seen brought forward the
um
the climate crisis of course is urgent
as we've just heard the queen's speech
sets out very little to address it the
draft energy security bill won't address
the short-term struggles with household
bills or help improve energy efficiency
the most cost-effective way to
permanently reduce energy bills and mr
deputy speakers ironically while i've
been stood here
sat here waiting to speak i've had the
email from my energy supplier telling
that my
monthly direct debit is doubling now on
my mp salary i can manage that most
people in this chamber will be able to
manage that but so many of our
constituents won't be able to manage
that they need our help and they need it
now
stephanie peacock thank you mr deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to follow my
honorable friend
across barnsley east people are really
worried about the cost of living for
many their biggest concern is the rising
cost of energy
a man from one well wrote me saying he
works two jobs his wife works another
they live together in a terrorist house
with their two children and they can no
longer afford to heat it
a local business in kendri have seen
their energy bills rocket from 3 800 to
over 15 000 pounds per year they
compared over 16 suppliers and this was
the best offer they could find
and a retired nurse living in
grimethorpe contacted me in great
distress
she lives off her nhs pension of just
over 16 000 pounds a year and has seen
her fuel balls double from 900 pounds to
2 000
being just over the qualification for a
fuel allowance she has no support to
help meaning she simply can't afford the
price rise having cared for others all
her life she is now being left uncared
for when ordinary working people and
local businesses can't afford heating
and food it's not just about the cost of
living but the cost of simply surviving
that has become too high today this
house will vote on whether to introduce
a windfall tax we have a choice between
letting gas companies keep the huge
profits that they have themselves
admitted are more than they know what to
do with or helping hard-working people
some of them who are most worried are
pensioners indeed for the retired the
basic state pension will also be worth
hundreds of pounds less in real terms
this year thanks to conservative
government's decision making this cut
will be especially hard for barnsley's
former miners who worked in dangerous
conditions to keep our country's lights
on only to have 50 of their pensions
pocketed by the government
just as ministers broke their promise to
protect the triple lock they have also
failed to review the mine workers
pension scheme
as recommended by the cross-party select
committee report this report concluded
that the government should not be in the
business of profiting from miners
pensions and indeed the prime minister
committed action in the last general
election on this issue yet the
government have taken 4.4 billion pounds
of miners money today this is set to
rise to 6 billion pounds while the
average miner receives a pension of just
84 pounds a week this queen's speech is
a missed opportunity to help those who
are struggling how high do prices have
to rise how many more pensioners must
freeze and how many children must live
in poverty before the government finally
steps
in late
who made a very powerful speech and uh
accounts that she made of some of her
constituents i think um
sadly chime with manny and kennedy gone
as well and it's on that topic i'd like
to to speak today by adding my own voice
uh to others who have spoken of the pain
that raising energy bills are causing
households the length and breadth of the
uk
um i'd argue that sadly the impact of
these raises
um is being felt quite acutely in wales
where even before the current crisis a
third of our children and nearly a
quarter of adults of working age lived
in poverty and uh i regret to note that
reports suggest that as many as
as much as 45
of households in wales could now be in
fuel poverty following the latest
energy price cap increase
and the experience of rural areas
underlines the urgent need for action
in addition to the increases arising
from a higher energy price cap they've
also seen large increases to already
high standing charges
for just take for example that the daily
rates for households in my constituency
of keratigun are on
an average 50 percent higher than those
levied in london and compounding the
crisis for my constituents is the fact
that some 35 of households are not
connected to the mains gas grid and as
such rely on heating oil on average they
have seen 150
increase to the cost of their fuel
deliveries when they are able to receive
deliveries that is as they are not
protected by the energy price cap
and however rising energy prices not
only squeeze household budgets but
coupled with higher fuel prices they
also threaten the rural rural economy
and risk stalking a wider social crisis
i take no pleasure from noting that
wales is the most car dependent nation
in the uk and that there needs to be
significant investment in our public
transport infrastructure
rising petrol and diesel prices have a
severe impact on public services
something that i think we sometimes
forget when
prices increase maintaining rural bus
routes and school transport services
become harder and perhaps more
worryingly it means that crucial workers
like social carers are finding it
difficult to afford to work in a
constituency like mine where there is a
higher on the national average of people
of
retirement and elderly and this is a
particular concern of ours now some
short-term relief could be gleaned from
the rural field due to relief scheme
might urge the government to extend it
to wales
now the crisis is having a real and
immediate impact on people across the uk
and it is amongst the most pressing
issues requiring government action and
as chair of the all-party parliamentary
group on full poverty i'd urge the
government to seriously consider
proposals put forward by the national
energy action for a new social tariff to
enhance protection for those most
vulnerable customers
such a proposal should be accompanied by
efforts to increase the visibility and
the support offered through schemes like
the discretionary assistance fund and
the extension of the warm home discount
and winter fuel payments to all
low-income households now doing so would
address the short-term pressures
emanating from higher energy prices but
a long-term solution would be a
significant increase in funding for
energy efficiency measures and in
particular the government will bring
forward equal four legislation without
delay to ensure that installation
measures are installed for the poorest
households as soon as possible so
definitely speaker in conclusion
the reports and the discussion this
afternoon suggests that the chancellor
may well be contemplating a one-off win
full tax on energy companies as i mean
as a means of partly funding such a
package of support and i'd like to let
him know that he'd enjoy the support of
many members on both sides of the house
so he decided to do so because families
in my constituency quite simply can't
afford the price of continued inaction
yeah anderson
thank you mr deputy speaker
the queen's speech had two challenges
one is to tackle the cost of living
crisis and the other the climate crisis
but i feel on behalf of my resident my
constituents in putney rowhampton and
southfields that it does neither
the number of people who are in energy
poverty has gone across the uk from four
million people last september to over
six million people now and will continue
to rise
and pensioners are at the sharp end of
the tory squeeze and finances they're
paying twice as much for energy and
facing the biggest real terms cuts to
the state pension in 50 years
on the other hand energy companies have
recorded record products project profits
of 12.4 billion pounds in the first
three months of this year alone
and petrol retailers are profiting from
the cut in petrol and diesel duty
keeping about 2p of the 5p that should
be passed on
the government have not got a grip of
these issues instead we need to have a
windfall tax on oil and gas producer
profits to bring down bills and an
emergency budget
for the last few days conservative mps
and ministers have been lining up to
show how out of touch they are and it
really worries me that this in on your
bike kind of thinking
is still guiding decision making
increasing poverty is not a failure of
budgeting it's not a failure of cooking
skills and it's not a failure of
magically being able to get a new job
dan lives in putney and he wrote to me
last weekend about his dilemma mr deputy
speaker he has two young children um
they can't afford child care his wife
stays at home to look after them he
works for 40 hours a week for 9 pounds
50. he's been offered additional hours
so he could take those additional 15
hours which would mean 60 hours a week
which would mean he would not see his
children very much that would give him
only with the resulting cut in universal
credit an extra 177 pounds a month and
the equivalent of two pounds 95 an hour
that is not a fair decision for him and
he says the system is broken for people
like me
it's for people like dan that the
queen's speech should have had more
policies a pensioner got in contact with
me she's got active crohn's disease and
she can't afford to turn on her heating
steve also wrote to me he's 77
self-employed and his
energy bills have gone up from 246
pounds to 890 pounds and he has no idea
how he will afford this
and they are just three people who are
examples of so many for all of our
constituents
onesworth food bank say that 6 out of 10
parents have skipped meals in the last
month to put food on the table for their
children instead
people on the lowest incomes are the
best at budgeting they are the best at
knowing how to make meals stretch
and they can't just work extra hours
in fact half of all referrals to
onesworth food banks are people in work
but their income doesn't cover the
essential bills so where was the
employment bill in the gracious speech
we also need to see the green homes
grant returned in the energy bill the
reef retrofit revolution really tackling
climate cha the climate emergency one
that covers all homes and is there for
10 years or more the boiler upgrade
scheme currently in place is really the
absolute least you could do we should do
so much more
on behalf of my constituents i demand
more action on the climate emergency
more action on employment rights
more action to actually tackle the cost
of living crisis and i hope that all mps
tonight will vote for the windfall tax
thank you
quickly
thank you mr speaker
for my constituency in back and ever
knows in similarly deployed sounds
around the country the governments have
been remarkable slightly remarkably
silenced about what they intend to do
but the cost of living crisis in their
legislative programme for the coming
year while some of those on the benches
opposite me have advised the poorest in
our in our country to take up quickly
lessons or to scour the shops for the
cheapest brands the government itself
has offered little more than scraps from
its table a 200 pound load here and 150
rebate day
such message give little comfort to
those who whose housing benefits has
been frozen since 2020 while rents have
skyrocketed they offer no long-term
solutions for those who benefits and
pensions have been caught and pegged
back nor do they help those in work who
face short on prices and falling wages
family budgets are our breaking points
two and five people are now buying less
through because of the cost of living
crisis in april two million adults
skipped the days eaten to try and save
money the resolution foundation predicts
that almost one and a half million
people including half a million children
will fall into absolute poverty next
year this is what food inflation of nine
percent and rising means for millions
this is what energy costs heading for a
54
increase our reflect on inflicting on
the poorest and most vulnerable people
in this country a hubsan's choice of
heat or eat
the cost of living crisis at war on the
poor it's a discourage of countless
working families scandalous at the time
when the ceo of tesco has just pocketed
a pay practice of almost five million
pounds for one year's work a customer
assistance at tesco would have to work
267 years to win the same as the ceo got
for 12 months a budget shame
the government that cares about his
people should be working towards both
short-term and long-term solutions in
his plans for the year ahead sadly this
government plans for very little beyond
its own self preservation short term we
can help people by institutions and win
for patent sacks on the fuel giants a
giant and their profits two big oil
companies coined in over 12 billion in
the first three months of this year
let's tax it to help those who can't
afford to hit their homes even soft
directors such as the ceo of aztec are
calling for this now let's restore the
20 pound universal credits uplift to
prevent the poorest
from sliding into innovation will food
and food and fuel poverty let's
immediately provide extra funds to hire
their pensioners through warm home and
which of you
extra payments and let's set a real
living wage at a level people can really
live on long term we need to to address
the economic problems at the heart of
our economy the legacy of industrial
vandalism by the party opposites over
many years we need to stimulate inward
investments by recasting our economy
through a green industrial revolution
this can provide hundreds of thousands
of well-paid jobs it can create
industries including i believe live and
publicly owned ones that meet our energy
needs on a clean and clean basis helping
to save our planet and it can overcome
the chronic failings of the current
supply chain we need a progressive
wealth tax also closes the loopholes
that enable the rich and the
corporations to evade the taxes they
rightfully owe fair taxation can pay for
the uplift and reform of the benefit
system which couldn't be punishes the
poor benefits and pensions must be
substantially increased and
inflation-proof
finally when the government control
weighs it must scrap the massively below
inflation pay limits that are really pay
cuts these cuts took an average of eight
hundred and forty five
five pounds away from the nhs workers
last year we clapped their efforts
during lockdown then the government
slashed their wages during crackdown
these are the answers to the cost of
living crisis and
there are measures that should be in the
legislative program for this year thank
you very much
christian wakeford
thank you mr speaker i listened with
great interest to the gracious speech
last week and was left bitterly
disappointed
this will go down as a speech of missed
opportunities all through the choice of
the prime minister
under this government we are heading
back to a time which was quite simply
about the haves and the have-nots you
can either afford the basics
or you suffer
workers are seeing a decline in their
living standards not seen since the
victorian era and the poor law of 1834.
a return to that miserable time in which
volunteers pull together to plug the
gaps whether purposefully underfunding
of a state left so many holes 80 years
ago beverage spoke of the five giant
evils that plagued society i'm afraid
that those on the opposite benches are
propping up on presiding over return of
those evils or they would be if we're
even here today
he spoke of want
this could have been a speech where the
concerns of a cost of living crisis that
is currently gripping the nation could
have been addressed with an emergency
budget or a bill to propose a windfall
tax on large energy companies
instead
food banks boom whilst people make a
choice between heating
um heating their homes and feeding them
or their children imagine a world in
2022 mr deputy speaker where one in four
parents are skipping meals because they
cannot afford it
one
and what solutions do those opposite
come up with
learn to cook
work harder
work longer
mr deputy speaker is absolutely shameful
he spoke of disease this was a speech
that showed that there was no plan for
our creaking health service and nhs
waiting times there's no plan to deal
with access to nhs dentistry there's no
plan to increase the number of gps
there's no plan to tackle either the
stigma or the problem of addiction which
is a matter close to my heart as members
of this chamber will know because no one
chooses to be an addict
he spoke of ignorance
no mr deputy speaker not the ignorant
shown by the prime minister and the
chancellor whilst they put their heads
in the sand but the education of our
children
the attainment gap is winding further
still and there is no plan inside yet
again
our children cannot learn properly if
they are hungry
our teachers cannot teach properly if
not supported yet nearly 18 000 schools
have faced brutal cuts to their funding
these children are the future of our
country and yet they are treated like
collateral damage by this government
he spoke of squalor
people across the country trapped in
their own homes covered in flammable
cloud cladding a full five years on from
the tragedy of grenfell this was a
speech where housing and planning
policies weren't even mentioned once
social housing waiting was spiraling
into the decades with merely rumors of a
rehash of right to buy from a prime
minister totally bereft of ideas and
increasingly out of touch
properties riddled with damp and mold
and making people ill here in the sips
richest economy in the
world he spoke of violence
and this could have been a speech where
employment rights were boosted and the
shocking practice of fire and rehire
finally brought to an end
instead
the government issued
further flimsy guidelines which allow
bosses to wipe roughshod over the
workers
over 20 times were promised an
employment bill but yet again this was
another empty promise for the people of
this country and another win for rogue
employers
finally madame deputy speaker this was a
speech that won't help those in need as
our country lurches from crisis to
crisis a speech where this government is
increasingly out of touch from its own
people and i predict a speech that will
no doubt unravel before the year is out
i will be voting against the queen's
speech for various reasons about the
deputy speaker
christine johnny
thank you very much
speaker it's
um at one time
both a privilege and a disappointment to
speak in this debate tackling the short
and long-term cost of living increases
because
we are tackling those
issues because we are in a crisis
which
is on a scale that we haven't seen in
this country for decades
we're talking about inflation towards
the end of the year moving up into
double figures
and interest rates going up
and the cost of living which takes us
back to the 1970s in a very difficult
time
for for many of us and for our parents
so
we're waiting for the government to
bring forward a paradigm changing vision
of what they're going to do about this
crisis
a plan instead of which all we got today
was a lecture about how the government
understands the need for long-term
growth and even more pointlessly a
reminder of what the labor government
may or may not have done 20 years ago
there was nothing
nothing in the plan for the people who
are facing a crisis today there was no
empathy for those people and there was
no understanding from the chancellor of
the difficulty that they are facing
nothing in the programme which is in the
queen speech for the families and the
pensioners in my constituency of
edinburgh west and across the country
who are struggling with the immediate
impact of the cost of living crisis not
in the future not in the long term but
now
today the rise in their food bills in
their clothes for themselves and their
children and their petrol to get to and
from work of their children to school
and the frightening prospect because it
is a frightening prospect for many of
them of a winter coping with ever higher
energy prices
so we have the chancellor's performances
about long-term growth well
unfortunately with this government we've
learned a long time ago that promises
are not worth the air into which they're
spoken
pensioners
don't have to be told they were promised
that the triple lock would continue and
now they find that the triple lock has
been abandoned for the moment leaving
them 500 pounds a year worse off too
many broken promises like too many
missed opportunities have made a
difference with insulation in our houses
before now and too much dither and delay
delay now on a windfall tax the
chancellor's got himself into the
situation where he says today that he's
consid you know he's considering it so
if he doesn't do it why hasn't he done
it and if he does now do it
why didn't he do it
sooner
and what about a cut on vat to put money
back into family's pockets cutting it
from 20 to 17
would make a huge difference to families
up and down this country and i hear the
opposition benches will want to say oh
well it will cost how much well it will
cost 19 billion but you see the
chancellor himself
is in for a bit of a windfall because
the increase in prices has meant that
he's going to get 38 billion pounds more
than he expected from v80
money which families up and down this
country who can now afford our spending
today
will go into the exchequer
but rather than cut vat
and put it back
into those families pockets those
pensioners pockets what is the
chancellor going to do about it
that is what we need to know that is
what we want to know what is the
chancellor going to do
time is running out for families up and
down this country time is running out
for this government they need to listen
to what people are saying it was clear
from the election results last week the
people are not happy they did not get
the government they thought they were
getting
it's time they listened they acted
and they recognized that the crisis is
now
not somewhere down the line
ian lavery thank you madam deputy
speaker
the
the debate that there's been really
interesting
on my dad but i i've got to say that
we've got to realize that this country
is one of the
richest countries on the planet
and we have got finances
it's which way we decide
how we distribute the wealth of this
nation
and if we cannot help the poorest if
we're going to help the people who are
suffering greatly
and this cost-living crisis in
uh we're doing something subtly wrong
you know we we look you know and
we look as mps we're here to represent
individuals
in the constituencies we shouldn't need
detailed reports we shouldn't need
professors or experts or anyone else to
tell with that poverty is rife in the
communities
rife in the constituency is what we
represent as it pays we should
understand that
unless i'm alone
because i say it in my constituency
i say the fact that people are
malnourished you know those people in
this country
there's people in this wonderful country
of ours
kids
suffering through malnutrition
we've got record levels of kids now with
rickets
oh here this is the uk
one of the richest planets
they're one of the richest countries on
the planet we've got
has been seen people missing meals to
feed their kids we've got food banks
two and a half million people now using
food banks for heaven's sake i'll tell
you what's new in my constituency madam
deputy speaker
nothing a rise in crime and shoplifting
we've got people who are desperate to
keep their kids clean stealing
products are stealing sanitary products
are stealing soup powder
this is an absolute outrage
and it isn't good enough to say that the
support's here man
it isn't good enough to abdicate your
responsibility saying we've done this
and not in 150 pound it appears you go
alone for electricity it's abdicating
your responsibility for people and most
indeed you know we've got this fella
bernard looney bernard lully the the
chief executive of one of the richest
companies on the planet he's basically
done everything but take barrel loads of
money to the treasury and tip it into
the hull a once and he said that he's
happy to have a windfall tax and can you
imagine what difference i could make to
people who we're talking about the deer
so you're telling me by the way that
it's okay you can make a meal for 30
pence so you should be all right it's
like you're telling me that the way to
get
over this issue of the the cost of
living crisis is to find a new job
somewhere like the pioneer like the
people who've been on fire and rehire
it's like you're telling me that people
should be working and have two or three
jobs and things will be okay we've got
to start addressing the situation we
can't continue the tories the
conservatives the government cannot
continue to turn a blind eye they can't
continue to walk by on the other side
while people are suffering greatly
we need to level up
we need to be truthful we need to level
up with the truth we need to be a
compassionate we need to be honest we
need to be this they're decent as
politicians
you know we should be out to support
those millions out there who absolutely
need every single
this government can provide
here
kate holler
thank you madam deputy speaker
last week in the queen's speech there
was 38 pieces of legislation
however there was nothing to address the
biggest challenge
families are facing up and down the
country a cost of living crisis which is
only going to get worse in months ahead
members opposite and on this side i've
spoken to the need for a long-term
strategy and of course there is
but that is little comfort to the people
who are suffering now
we need a short-term
support mechanisms put in place to help
families manage the budgets who are
concerned about stretching their pay
packets till the end of next week
we've got agonizing choices choices from
pensioners
who don't know whether they've hit their
home or eat some food
the cost of living crisis is here it's
now it's today
and people cannot
be left in the dire circumstances
they're in now
we need a windfall tax to reduce energy
bills we need an increase in pensions
and other benefits to keep up with
inflation
this money will not sit in people's
banks it'll be spent in the local
economy it'll be spent on local shops
they'll be spent on markets
madam deputy speaker i'd like to set out
stories of a few of my constituents to
make sure that you know exactly what
we're talking about here today
stories like violet who's over 80 are
important
violet suffers from motor neuron disease
she doesn't cook and receives meals on
wheels she was astonished to find her
energy bill went up by 500 pounds she's
extremely worried and stressed about how
she'll manage
isabel suffered a stroke last week tells
me she's turned off her heating
she said she'll manage but again is
extremely worried
emma a single mom she's in work not in
benefits who after paying rent gas
electric water
has none of
wages left for bear essentials or the
local firm brought to the brink of brink
of closure by rocket and energy costs
so why isn't this government ready to
exhaust all options to support these
people
why hasn't the government caught on to
the urgency
of this moment
why are government ministers poking fun
at the idea of an emergency budget to
support people
the queens speak with a major
opportunity to support those most
affected by rising costs and the
government didn't take it
and an opportunity to change course and
it refused
i have serious concerns that the party
opposite have totally missed the point
they just do not know what it feels like
to worry about whether you pay your rent
or buy food for your children
and it's clearly shown in the statements
we've seen recently and they've been
said and i'm pleased that everybody
recognizes
just how ridiculous some of those
statements were residents of are left
behind in blackburn will be hard to set
by rising costs
average earnings in blackburn is 25 000
pounds while the uk average is 38 000
pounds
we cannot let financial burden hit those
who have already been hit the hardest
today is an opportunity for this
government to do the right thing
sure they understand and dare i say even
show they care about the millions of
people in this country struggling
through no fault of their own and
support a windfall tax to help ease the
burden on families
we might manage to get everybody in i'll
have to reduce the time limit
to three minutes after the next speaker
kenny mccaskill
i'm deputy speaker
all speeches especially portsy program
for government take place in a context
in a backdrop
that's just the rising cost of living
but from scotland it's the utter
perversity that we have a land that is
energy rich and yet we have so many
scots who are fuel poor
oil and gas in 2014 we were told was
literally valueless and would soon be
gone is now worth a fortune and the uk
sees it as being exploited for decades
to come
but it extends beyond that because we
have renewables not simply having been
blessed with hydro and indeed unsure
when we now have offshore wind coming at
the saudi arabia wind with 25 of
europe's resource in scotland but
where's the benefits to our community
where is the oil fund that norway has
that we can only look at and lament
where is the benefit from offshore wind
when the jobs are going abroad and the
revenue is going south there is a
perversity in my constituency of people
who can see the energy wealth and yet
are unable to heat their own home it's
not the fault or all the fault of
ukraine of course it's a factor but
there are many more including the
profits being made which is why i
support a
windfall tax because there's certainly
been a win for many of the corporate
executives but we have the absurdity and
the indignity of a third of scots now
facing fuel poverty and rising over half
in the islands and indeed in areas of
deprivation and let's be clear we're not
talking about the invidious choice of
heating or eating or that appalling
expression and euthanism of our
self-disconnection it's not
self-disconnection it's disconnection
forced by political decision making and
political choice they have no
alternative it is not an accident it is
a political decision
and let's also remember it's not the
choice between heating or eating it goes
beyond that
it's the person who wants to charge up
their phone because you need to power
your phone you need a phone to live
these days because you want to be
contactable for employment it's the
mother who wants to wash their clothes
so the kids can go smart to school even
if they've had to be bought in a charity
shop it's a child who's been given an
ipad because comes from a deprived part
and they want to try and level up and
his mum can't put their power on it's a
person on dialysis who's sitting having
to keep themselves alive and has to make
that choice of keeping their power on
and what do they not spend upon so
that's a situation yes there's things
that have to be done that cost money but
the things that are remarkably cheap
what about unregulated fuel because
we've seen the cost rise of electricity
and gas but what about lpg and
especially heating oil and biomass seven
percent of scotch you're on unregulated
fuel why can that not be regulated and
at least capped when a cat is imposed
because everybody knows the costs of
heating oil have gone up far more than
the cost of electricity and gas and
they've been left behind and what about
prepaid meters because we have the
negative in our country that those who
have the least pay the most those who
are dependent upon prepaid meters are
not simply those who are forced there by
choice many of them have no alternative
because their private landlord insists
upon it and yet they pay a higher tariff
they pay higher standing charges and
there is no reason for that it's not a
technical decision forced by the
complexity of metering it comes about
because the government will not direct
off gem to enforce it the companies
could do it and equal as my friend the
honourable member for canadian said
there's a time now for a social tariff
and indeed a disability tariff other
countries do it belgium does it portugal
and spain have actions so those who have
leased are protected that does mean that
those who have more such as myself and
other members here might have to pay a
slightly higher rate but indeed it can
be done as well as the money coming in
from the windfall tax this isn't a
situation we find by accident it's a
political decision and it has to change
we now have a time limit of three
minutes wendy chamberlain
madam deputy speaker it's a pleasure to
be back after prorogation and the local
elections but less of a pleasure to be
debating the government's legislative
agendas laid out in the queen's speech
the cost of living crisis is not just
biting undiscovered leadership but it is
knowing away to the bone what people
need what my constituents need is an
emergency budget and members on the
opposite side were crowing earlier about
the low unemployment rate but failed to
mention that we now see economically
inactive data of over 21 percent how do
we expect to see productivity grow when
a fifth of the country are not working
the right honourable member for east ham
and his opening remarks mentioned lloyd
george and it would be remiss of me as a
liberal not to do so myself so based on
what he said he said as a proportion of
earnings benefits are now lower than
when lloyd george introduced a
unemployment benefit in 2011 and based
on my calculation of unemployment of
seven shillings a week and median
earnings then of about 30 that means
about 22.5
currently universal credit is 334 pounds
per month for a single person over 25
and median earnings are 2061 pounds per
month that equates to 16
and the government's choice not to
uplift benefits in line with inflation
has only exacerbated this divide perhaps
time with appg for ending the need for
food banks of which i co-chair launched
a new inquiry just last week we kicked
off with a visit to a food bank in
hackney and i can tell the minister with
certainty that telling families to take
more shifts is not a viable or
appropriate policy solution
in my constituents northeast 5 families
are also turning to charities such as 5
gingerbread providing a tea time club so
ovens and microwaves don't have to be
put on providing help in the school
holidays so parents can work just to or
help provide extra energy costs and this
year a new fundraising campaign is
helping to provide families with a day
out over the summer holidays because all
children deserve to learn and play and
laugh and from the very young madame
deputy speaker right up to the elderly
others have mentioned the waspi women
but i would ask why the government is
still refusing to follow expert advice
on the leap state pension exercise and
continuing to exclude divorced women why
does it think that the dwp made
continued errors over several decades in
relation to married and widowed women
and doesn't think that it did the same
for divorced women i urge them to look
at that increasingly older people are
also left to rely on the voluntary
sector for support and i call out cosy
kingdom who provide home assessments and
advice and energy savings in northeast
life a handyman service for those who
would otherwise struggle with jobs like
in strolling draft protection and
dealing with benefits and debt and
increasingly priority creditors such as
energy providers all these issues are
exacerbated when you live in rural
constituencies such as my own the
government as again is falling far short
on its commitments
two million british people can't afford
to eat every day over seven million are
considered to be food insecure and over
two and a half million children say that
they cut down on the amount they eat or
don't eat when they're feeling hungry
but these are not just data these are
not just statistics these are real
people and here are some of the messages
that i've received from constituents in
whole western hazel one person tells me
about they're paying over 320 pounds
more on their standing charges before
they even use energy they're trying to
budget but they can't they feel
victimized for being a low energy user
another one tells me they've worked out
they should have a hundred pounds a
month left after the cost of everything
goes up on universal credit single
person over 24 but has diabetes and
other health content conditions another
lady linda she worked full time until
she was 74. she's now 77 living on a
state pension she says because i try to
be sensible and save some money i'm
penalized and i will not i only get
pension savings credit not guaranteed
pension credit she's worried about the
future and these go on and on and on
madam deputy speaker we are facing the
worst cost of living crisis in a
generation but you wouldn't know it from
having listened to the speech made by
the government and the shameful slurs
and struggling families about their
failure to budget or cook
i think i should be utterly disregarded
and ignored and shows how out of touch
the government is
so what can we do about this well i have
to say thanks of course to all the
charities faith groups and business
people in whole western hazel for the
work they are doing and particularly i
want to mention a local business from
gerard toplast who's made an offer
across all his businesses to increase
money going home for staff who earn less
than 50 000 pounds a year and he said we
believe this is both an acknowledgement
that we understand the pressures people
are under and a practical demonstration
of how important we believe our people
are he's giving all of his workers an
extra 60 pounds a month an example that
i do hope other businesses across the
country look to follow the government
could also increase national universal
credit payments cancel the national
insurance increase cut credit and fuel
and of course windfall tax but there is
one more thing madame gets a speaker
that i think they will jump at the
chance to implement because it is
cost-free measure which i am going to
give them as an option to take away and
that's looking at addressing the poverty
premium the poverty premium as a member
outline there is an aspect where poorer
people have to pay more for financial
services for energy for insurance and
things like that and with their
financial services and markets bill what
the government could do
is instruct the financial services and
markets authority and give them a clear
remit on financial inclusion by
including an aspect called have regards
that is a cost-free way to make a
difference to some of the families
struggling the most and i hope the
government will take this opportunity
and if they do they can guarantee on
support from myself
ellie reeves thank you madam deputy
speaker after 12 years of a conservative
government taxes are at their highest
level in 70 years and we are seeing the
biggest drop in living standards since
the 1950s food prices increasing heating
bills going up wages stagnating and the
bank of england forecasting growth to go
negative next year the conservatives
claim to be the party of economic
responsibility but this is their record
in government
and at my local food bank romney
livingwell demand is soaring in march
last year they gave out food for just
over 600 people
this march they gave out food for well
over 1 000 people
one of those was a young single mother
in work who had to visit the food bank
after buying a school uniform for her
son's new school left her without any
money for food she was in tears because
she never thought she would have to use
a food bank and only wanted to take the
bare minimum
and one of living wells regular users
has started requesting food that doesn't
require cooking because they don't have
the money to pay to
the fuel to cook the food
and whilst rising food and energy prices
hit us the government decided to hit
working people with a tax rise
no other major economy is doing this in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
yet ours is
one of my constituents a full-time carer
for those with learning disabilities
wrote to me about their situation
their rent energy bills council tax and
travel come to
400 pounds a month and their take-home
pay comes to 1 600
leaving 200 pounds a month for food and
clothes for their children and this was
their situation even before the national
insurance increase
to get by my constituent has to take 14
hour shifts at the weekends and goes to
bed hungry at night she says that as
things stand she'll be left either
homeless or in huge debt and frankly
it's shameful that a message to her from
those on the government benches is to
work more hours or get a better paid job
these cases are not unique to my
constituency across the country millions
of people are feeling the crunch from
the cost of living crisis that's why
labour recalling for an emergency budget
would use it to scrap the national
insurance hike and bring in a one-off
whimfield tax on oil and gas producers
to cut household energy bills how can it
be right madam deputy speaker that
whilst my constituents worry about
turning the radiators on the boss of bp
has doubled his salary to 4.5 million
pounds a year
the queen's speech is an opportunity for
the government to show they're in touch
with reality and on the side of working
families it was an opportunity to show
they understand the challenges people
are facing but they failed
madam deputy speaker tonight those on
the conservative benches have an
opportunity to show they understand the
very real impact of the cost of living
prices by voting for labour's amendment
calling for a whimple tax for the sake
of my constituents and theirs i hope
that they are finally listening and that
they do the right thing
david lyndon thank you very much indeed
madame deputy speaker i think for most
people watching this on tv tonight we'll
be intrigued with the fact that we refer
to the gracious speech but the
overwhelming message in my constituency
of glasgow east is that this was an
inadequate speech because there were a
number of things that were missing from
the queen's speech that we would like to
have seen for example and many other
members of reference that there's the
employment bill i think the cat was
rather let out the bag the honourable
gentleman who sits from bedford who's no
longer in his place we spoke about the
importance of deregulation and i think
for most of us who have been concerned
for quite some time that the uk
government's idea of brexit was about
deregulation and that was about
attacking workers rights as well
and i accept that ideologically myself
and the government we are absolutely
opposed in so many issues but what i
would ask the government to reflect on
is that there are a hundred thousand
babies born every single year who are
born premature are sick there is
cross-party agreement in this house for
neonatal leave-in pay the government has
committed to it and yet again there is
going to be another year when that
doesn't come into play so i understand
that there'll be aspects of an
employment bill that'll be controversial
but i would ask the government to look
favorably upon the areas where we do
agree and bring that as standalone
legislation
one thing i do want to talk about as
well this evening is that the comments
that i think are typical of the uk
government at the moment that we saw
from the unbelievable member for
redditch i have given her advanced
notice that i planned to reference her
um
the irony of somebody in a hundred and
six thousand pounds a year thumbnail
around to clerical assistance in easter
house refuse collectors in carmilla
and people who work
in the
retail sector and shelves and the idea
that hundred and something a hundred and
six thousand pounds a year turns around
to them and tells them that they have to
work more or they have to get a better
job it shows just how completely
disconnected from reality this
government is
but as well as calling out the
honourable leader member for relics i do
want to please donald member for
litchfield who went and visited his
local food bank has come away come to
the house of commons this week and said
quite quickly to the government that
they need to operate benefits i think
that shows that when when members on the
government benches actually interact
with our constituents actually connect
to reality they will see
that far too often this government falls
so far short of the support that's
required so yes i absolutely support a
windfall tax on energy companies i'd
like to see it go further i'd like to
see it apply to the amazons of this
world if we're serious and understanding
that there are changes to retail the way
our high streets operate the reality is
the amazon are the big beneficiary of
that and yes let's look at a windfall
tax for them as well there are other
things we can do madame deputy speaker
we can look at reducing that on energy
bills we can look at reinstating that 20
pounds to universal credit
but the thing that i want to finish on
is that my local newspaper in glasgow
glasgow times was running a campaign to
beat the squeeze i think that is
entirely commendable and i would commend
the glasgow times to anybody in this
house
but i've got to say it should not fall
to a local newspaper to tell people how
to get through this cost of living
crisis we should be looking at tax and
likes of shell not high corrupt cash
insurance some people from shetleston
steve
bonner deputy speaker for months we have
sat here listening to those opposite
throttle excuse after excuse as to why
the pandemic was solely to blame for the
cost-loving crisis people were
experiencing nowadays four nations find
themselves and seemingly complete free
fall and the people out there living
through this crisis in desperate
situations while the government does
nothing and mitigation this is no
alternate cost-eleven crisis this is
authority cost a lot of increases when
every country on the planet experienced
the pandemic in some way shape or form
as the citizens of the uk who seem to be
suffering the most now
sky-high energy bills no action from the
government key workers like nurses
relying on food banks to feed their
families no action from the government
2.5 million people using food banks no
action from this government a particle
at a political food prices a politic
sorry food prices
no action from this government and
brexit costing us over 400 million
pounds every single week a torrey brexit
thriving across eleven crisis and what
solutions have they brought forward 38
new laws in the queen's speech but zero
solutions for right now zero relief
right now for struggling families and
individuals no benefit uplift no
subsidised electricity or gas payments
not even as much as our food voucher for
our most vulnerable citizens nothing
from a bereft prime minister and a
largely awol chancellor hiding behind it
issues
yet not a day goes by without somewhere
with perils of wisdom coming from the
out of touch morally redundant back
benches of this tory party whereby they
suggest to people utterly contemptible
methods of dealing with a crisis
inflicted on people by them made watched
by them and reinforced daily from this
place by them the member for ashfield is
not in his place madame deputy speaker
but i have given him her a reference i
was looking to mention him today meals
for 30 pence on the condition of our
cooking lesson and i'm supposed to be
coming back next week to tell us how we
should cook that when the people can't
afford to put a fiver on their
electricity meet us
people people earning the money that we
mps adam will lecture and desolate
people on budgeting really as
reprehensible the reality is work health
rights have been decimated zero hour
contracts are commonplace vacancies may
well be at an all-time high but firing
higher has they been banned companies
can sack workers on zoom and man handle
them off for sites and this government
does nothing about it scotland does not
accept us but we have to endure it
with every passing day the uk government
fails to use its reserve powers to
tackle the cost delivering crisis as
demonstrating to us and the people of
scotland that independence is the only
way for scotland to boost our incomes
and build that fair
margaret greenwood
thank you madam deputy speaker this
morning it was reported that a poll
carried out on behalf of the royal
college of physicians found that more
than half of the people that they
surveyed had seen their health
deteriorate as a result of the cost of
living crisis the national institute for
economic and social research has said
that more than a quarter of a million
households will slide into destitution
next year taking the total number in
extreme poverty to around 1.2 million
unless the government acts to help the
poorest families the government should
never have cut universal credit by 20
pounds a week and taken away support
from the people who need it most the
government could have used this queen's
speech to come forward with the greatest
support for people facing rising bills
funded by windfall tax on oil and gas
companies so why have they not done so
the government says that helping people
into work is the best approach to
managing the cost of living over the
long term but the long-promised
employment bill is nowhere to be seen
and there is no ban on fire and rehire
leaving people vulnerable to poverty and
exploitation through insecure work
the government says it wants to quote
spread opportunities and improve public
services but how can such a claim be
taken seriously when they've inflicted
devastating cuts on local authorities
like world council since 2010 people in
world west know exactly what
conservative government policies lead to
they lead to the closure of vital
services the future of wood church
leisure centre and the libraries in hoi
lake irby pensbe and woodchurch hang in
the balance dependent on local people
taking over the running of them if the
government were serious about levelling
up they would fund local councillors
properly
if the government is to spread
opportunity it must take action to
address the crisis in adult literacy the
national literacy trust estimates that
there are more than seven million adults
in england with very poor literacy
skills
people who struggle to read and write
can face great hardship in life they can
experience difficulty in securing
housing dealing with utility companies
and managing financial affairs and they
can struggle to find secure and
well-paid work the government cannot say
it is leveling up the uk without
addressing this crisis the government
had the opportunity in the queen's
speech to make a commitment to ban
conversion therapy but instead it has
fallen short by not providing for
forthcoming legislation to apply to
trans people the british medical
association has described conversion
therapy
as an unethical and damaging practice
that preys on victims of homophobia
transphobia discrimination and bullying
it should be banned finally i turn to
the environment and climate change
and climate emergency the government
should be taking decisive action against
dirty fossil fuels and it's extremely
disappointing that is not brought
forward measures to ban fracking and
underground coal gasification these are
risky technologies and detrimental to
our fight against climate change they
should be banned
alex sobel
thank you madam speaker
uh this queen's speech the government
where uh this queen speaks the
government's faced with the twin
challenge of the cost of living crisis
and a climate crisis in a period we're
emerging from the greatest pandemic in a
hundred years the times call for a big
brave response ensuring we have a
game-changing policy that makes energy
secure with rapid rapid decarbonization
weaning us off gas at the same time with
rising prices and stagnant wages people
needed relief especially the most
essential bills including energy water
housing and transport
the measures over the last few months
and in this queen's speech feels like
the government abandoned cop 26 as soon
as the doors of the sec were closed it's
not just individuals and families faces
crisis but business who have the highest
cost pressures and highest tax burden in
50 years the party opposite thinks it's
the party of business but the pandemic
taught us it's only the case if it's
your chums who own the business the
millions who work in smes who weren't
fortunate to go to school or run the
local pub of a cabinet minister get no
help at all is the
democracy response to a crisis this
queen's speech hour provides not an
ounce of relief for those struggling
with costs and in dire need of a pay
rise to meet the proposed challenge we
need an energy security bill which is a
quantum leap in ambition to what the
government provides so far i would
expect a minimum to see from the bill a
retrofit revolution not a repeat of
failed previous schemes like the green
homes grant we need a serious delivery
body to deliver
adequate insulation for every building
in britain serious funding sector mass
apprenticeship program stellar leaping
decarbonisation involving district
heating power heat pumps and hydrogen an
annual target of reduction of household
energy bills and real term carbon
emissions reductions the future systems
operate needs to have real teeth to be
able to create a two-way smart grid take
advantage of battery storage and home
electricity generation
we need to deliver the much-needed
windfall tax on energy as as nearly
everybody particularly on this side of
the chamber has called for but we need
to go further we need measures on energy
price crap which need to be real and
offer real protection the current cap
doesn't balance excessive energy
produced profits against costs
why is it a mechanism to smooth the
profits against the costs of consumers
built in the long term
and while the government lifting their
ban on onshore wind
polling shows it's popular if community
owned and it's one of the cheapest
renewable technologies with double
capacity we could power 10 million homes
weaning them off gas
and also why did the government cut the
solar feed in traffic decimated domestic
solar market and stopped people in
houses getting
solar particularly in social houses
there's a minimum the government should
in uh in state a social feeding tariff
finally on food banks we've heard a lot
about that in this queen's speech food
banks are staying on our site it's
exposed to poverty the government
allowed people to fall into no one looks
forward to using a food bank no one is
proud of using a food bank let's see
that 20 pounds of universal credit
return to people this government isn't
just lacking in ambition it's failing
failing big time
kim johnson thank you madam deputy
speaker chronic tory under investment in
our public services and our communities
has meant that we have barely begun to
recover from the last recession and
we're standing on the brink of another
with inflation now predicted to exceed
10 percent the combination of soaring
food and fuel prices alongside inflation
and low pay are driving millions into
poverty hardship and hunger for my
constituents in liverpool riverside and
across the country the queen speech
provides little hope or comfort for
those experiencing extreme poverty
pensioners forces spend the day on buses
just to keep warm children going to
school hungry private renters terry fry
they're not going to be able to keep a
roof over their heads household finances
are breaking point and bad bosses
driving down wages and working
conditions driving um work poverty
through the roof while the reach richest
one percent the wealthy individuals
corporations and energy giants are
reporting eye watering record profits
the bosses shall receive 1.1 million pay
rise while the governor of the bank of
england is telling workers not to ask
their employers for a pay rise this is
the height of hypocrisy and no matter
what pathetic and insulting excuses this
government gives for the last 12 years
of failures to support struggling
families telling poor people to take
cooking lessons get a better paid job or
um
shopping for bargain brands poverty is a
political choice and this government has
chosen not to support those most in need
forcing working people into food banks
forced to make the impossible choice
between heating and eating while the
profits of the wealthiest go through the
roof and this stark reality is this is a
class war nowhere is more devastating
than the soaring rate of child poverty
in liverpool riverside the equivalent of
10 children and a class of 30 already
living in poverty
a record-breaking 2 30 of these children
are living in working families and
that's why i've moved an amendment to
the queen's speech that includes
measures to address skyrocketing levels
of child poverty these are clear simple
actions that prove the cost of living
crisis isn't inevitable it's a political
choice we need action and we need action
now bringing a willful tax minimum wage
of 15 pounds an hour reinstate and
extend the 20 pound uplift to universal
credit and all benefits
um
and instead of levelling up the tories
are doing what they do best leveling
down the west of the cost of living
crisis is yet to come and that's why i
urge all across the house today to
support this amendment thank you deputy
speaker ruth jones
oh thank you madam deputy speaker called
me to speak in this important debate and
i take part on behalf of the many
families in newport west who've written
to me called me and messaged me with
their stories their experiences and
their fears for the months and years
ahead
one resident in newport west wrote to me
recently and she said this
we are in a position right now where
we're not coping our energy bills have
risen 54
and i'm afraid that myself and many
others will not be able to provide for
our families
my husband's parents are on a state
pension of 82.45 a week we are concerned
for their welfare as they cannot afford
to heat their home nor pay for food if
these energy prices continue
she goes on many of my friends are
concerned for their own families too
we're all struggling and instead of
living we are surviving day to day
another woman from newport west wrote to
me and she said i have one daughter 12
years old i am in full-time employment
but yet on benefits i have cancer
even before the surge in any energy
prices many people like me have been
struggling to afford the essentials
the cost of weekly food shopping has
risen so has the cost of energy my rent
has also increased recently i've had to
make cutbacks on most things
now the people of west of newport west
as i said are looking for help but there
was nothing to help people with heating
their homes nothing to help with filling
their cars with fuel and no help for
people with feeding their families
that's why labour wants to introduce a
one-off windfall tax on oil and gas
producer profits so we can bring down
bills and bring them down now
and i hope the honourable members on the
other side of this house will finally
join the british people in calling for
this windfall tax or maybe properly
explain why they continue to oppose
measures that would ease the cost of
living crisis and make people's lives
better yeah
last year i spoke in this house about
the many thousands of people in newport
west who had their universal credit cut
and since then i've seen for myself the
devastating impact that decision had on
families in newport west and across
wales and we will not let tory minister
forget it
but it isn't just universal credit madam
deputy speaker all the people and
pensioners are at the sharp end of the
tory costa living crisis and they
urgently need the government to act now
pensioners spend twice as much on their
energy bills as those under 30 and face
spiraling inflation with the price of
petrol food and energy all soaring and
let's not forget that almost one in five
pensioners now live in poverty
and our young people are facing the
fierce winds of this crisis low wages
rising rents and cost of living going
through the roof
madam deputy speaker i will continue to
call this government out and i will
continue to stand up for the people of
newport west who knew change and need it
now
beth winter
deputy martin speaker
living standards in the uk are
plummeting under this conservative
government working class people are
suffering my constituents in the canon
valley are suffering and i want the
government to know what my constituents
think now i've recently completed a cost
of living survey in my constituency and
within a couple of days we had in excess
of 650 responses and the preliminary
findings of the survey are shocking and
harrowing and that's pretty
mildly 90 percent of respondents said
they feel worse than they did
this time last year 80
are reporting that financial
difficulties are impacting on the mental
health and i want to give you a flavor
of what people are enduring people like
bueno who is a
single parent who self-employed and she
says and i quote
these prices increase these price
increases are making me feel ill
depressed and are giving me sleepless
nights due to worrying i feel like a
failure for having to ask my children to
limit the heating eating less not eating
things they enjoy not having days out or
treats
another constituent harry who was
retired and again i want to quote what
he um says
he commented that
i'm desperately worried about playing my
increased utility bills i'm retired on a
fixed income i'd have to stop using the
central heating and i can't think what
else to do
i will be publishing for in the next
couple of weeks and i'll make sure that
the government gets a copy of the report
so i'm absolutely incensed the queen's
speeches ignored the action needed to
help people with the cost of living
crisis
instead the queen's speech proposes a
series of bills that fail to level up
communities or incomes and the failed to
deal with regional and national
inequality
bills like the level up bill which
should deal with inequality but it won't
the procurement bill which should be
without sourcing waste but it won't
what the government is pursuing a
draconian attacks on civil liberties
through the public order bill the bill
of rights the boycott bill the higher
education bill that allow the government
to deal with dissent and the government
has left out the promised employment
bill and it continues to treat the
sackings of piano as a joke through its
inadequate harbours uh bill
what we need as of they're already fed
is an emergency budget to announce
measures necessary to deal with a cost
of living crisis a windfall tax on gas
and oil giants and a wealth tax we
should also boost incomes we should
increase social security in line with
inflation
and we should
ensure that the government does respect
the devolution agreement it is clear to
me that the government in action is
uncaring leading to misery for millions
and millions of people and the empty
benches opposite says in all that we
need to know about how much this
government is about thank you order
john mcnally
speaker this queen's speech totally must
dismiss
the cost of living crisis facing my
constituents and focus as our community
made from two years dominated by the
pandemic and all the personal loss pain
and anxiety that came with it there is
now a brittle financial crisis to face
price rises are hitting families from
every site energy bills are storing the
price of basic food stuff is up fuel is
more expensive and inflation has reached
a 30-year high and going north
millions of people who have already cut
back having to choose between hitting
their homes feeding their children they
can't cut back anymore the waspi woman
pensioners many personal friends i grew
up with are living in fear of opening
their bills putting fuel in their cars
and they've had to stop giving to local
charities what a state of affairs to be
going through at their age
age scotland states that the 3.1 rise in
the state pension falls far short of
what is actually needed by our
pensioners and as highlighted by the
oecd the uk has one of the lowest public
pension schemes in the developed world
the uk is the highest percentage of
retirees over 65 at risk of poverty
among neighboring countries and that is
pitiful and to add insult to injury the
uk state pension provides retirees with
an income around 20 percent of the
average national wage compared to almost
40 percent across the oecd a disgrace
and an insult treating people and
pensioners with disdain an independent
scotland will have full power to protect
improve both state and occupational
pensions i believe this cost of living
crisis has been created by the
conservatives and brexit has only made
matters worse the snp repeatedly warned
that brexit would be damaging to
business anti-trade and that it would
put food prices up and yet the tory
government still remains dangerously out
of touch they could have reversed the
cuts to universal credit but it didn't
they could have cut that fuel bills they
could reduce back on the high street it
could tax companies not only energy
companies and excess profits and it
could increase benefits but it hasn't
madam deputy speaker the tory mps who
demonstrated are not a lack of humanity
with the recent views that struggling
families should buy cheaper food manage
money better that people who use food
banks cannot cook properly let me tell
them this there are three members here
and in the lawns you could hardly peel a
potato have never bought a dinner plate
to their own table never mind make a
meal such as the sense of entitlement to
finish this story government message is
very clear you live in your world and i
live comfortably in mind it's poverty
versus privilege thank you
alex davis
speaker um the cost of living crisis is
impacting people across pontique and
tafili but madame deputy speaker it
doesn't have to be this way as my right
honourable friend the member for
doncaster north is quite rightly and
powerfully set out there are many urgent
short-term measures to help families
through the cost of living crisis that
this government have simply neglected to
implement and really madam debt to
speaker what people need across the
country are long-term solutions that is
why i am both furious and frustrated
that the government have backtracked
once again on their promises to bring
forward an employment bill central to
tackling the cost of living crisis is to
ensure that workers across the board are
fairly protected and an issue
particularly personal for me is that we
were told that this bill would finally
finally introduce proper neonatal leave
and pay for new parents and the minister
stood at that dispatch box only a few
months ago and told the house that the
government remained very committed to
introducing neonatal even pay via the
employment bill but because of this
government's decision to abandon this
bill thousands of new parents will have
no choice but to continue to balance
precarious work and family commitments
proper neonatal even pay could have
brought so much desperately needed
relief to these new families as they
struggle through the cost of living
crisis they were struggling even before
the cost of living crisis took hold
which is why it is even more insulting
that they have been abandoned yet again
by this tory government in fact the tuc
of taliadap ministers promised an
employment pill on nearly 20 occasions
now that this promise has been abandoned
is it any wonder that the public trust
in this government is so low
unsurprisingly neonatal pay is not the
only crushing disappointment in his
half-hearted gracious speech my
constituents in ponte preventafili
desperately needed this speech to
genuinely engage with the cost of living
crisis we need bold proposals we are an
emergency budget we need a new windfall
tax on north sea oil and gas companies
we need an urgent nationwide
installation program to prevent energy
loss and reduce families energy bills
but what did we get instead a bill
promising to further crack down on the
fundamental right to protest a vaguely
leveling up bill promising to let
residents decide street names and a bill
promising to flog channel 4 to the
highest bidder madame deputy speaker
this is a government that has run out of
road when ministers try to defend it all
they do is insult the british public
further
we have food poverty fuel poverty and
now hygiene poverty and the fact that
these even have to exist in modern
britain should be ashamed to every
single member or lack of members on the
government benches it is a devastating
economic truth that households are
having to spend less meaning sectors
like entertainment and hospitality are
losing out our economy shrinks we're all
poor foreign speaker i could go on and
on and on but as you see i'm angry my
constituents are angry i will continue
to do everything i can to get the people
of ronda conantaff the help that they
need but this speech is an insult to the
thousands of households in wales and
across the uk who need real immediate
solutions to help with the cost of
living crisis and i urge this government
to act and act now yeah
in but yeah
thank you madam deaf new speaker last
week should have been extremely sobering
moments in this house the few foundation
figures widely quoted in this chamber
should chill the souls of every member
that saves here with millions going
hungry in our communities
a few days before the queen's speech was
delivered i spoke to a disabled
constituent who explained to me of the
cost of living and used increasing
energy bills left him choosing between
heating his home or powering his
electric wheelchair
the fifth vicious country in the world
there was nothing in the queen's feet to
make sure he does not have to face this
unjust situation a day longer instead
the shoulder reflects on how we fix the
crisis we have grotesque suggestions
from across the opposite side of the
house on cookery classes or maybe an
hour with mary betty to fix the problem
of millions going hungry now the
government suggesting it's the fault of
the person in poverty that they just
need to pack in their zero our minimum
wage contract job and maybe become the
ceo of apple
we need to weigh less
of condescending rhetoric laying the
blame on the people facing hardship and
poverty from commentators and
politicians
you've got about as much experience of
poverty as i have of attending the
annual reunion and the london club
madame deputy speaker let's be clear the
blame for this crisis was with this
failing government
and who could make the political
decisions that's needed if they wanted
to
the government could decide to put a
rate of food into legislation they could
ban fire in the ayah they could answer
the other contracts they could raise the
level of universal credit legacy
benefits and minimum wages they could
protect pensioners and they could
deliver justice for the 9 000 women in
libya west derby impacted by the change
the women's state pension age
hunger is a political choice
fuel poverty is a political choice all
choices could only be made by this
government this is an emergency life and
death for many which demands serious
solutions not tinkering with a system
that's utterly broken for millions
that's why we need to legislate for the
light of food we need enforceable food
rights to ensure the government of the
day is accountable for making sure
nobody goes hungry and so it is
prevented from making decisions that
lead to people being unable to afford to
put a meal on the table or put the
heating gun
madam deputy speaker this is why i have
table and amendments to the korean
speech to enshrine a right to food and
uk law and i'd like to thank every
member who supported it right across
this house and urge your other members
to support it thank you
martin day deputy speaker i'm very
grateful i probably shouldn't be that
surprised that this queen's speech does
nothing to tackle the tory's cost of
living crisis because they have done
virtually nothing over the recent years
under underlying causes many of my
constituents fall into the group's
hardest hit being the poorest the
elderly and those in the most remark
remote parts of the country they are
being hammered by soaring inflation fuel
and energy prices yet this government
has continually dragged its feet over
the energy crisis and has to be forced
into debating fuel poverty and energy
price caps but sadly without any
effective outcomes
the publication of the energy strategy
and announcement of the energy bill
offers nothing to help either the cost
of living crisis or to help improve
energy efficiency which would
permanently help to reduce people's
bills
energy prices have risen
harder and impact hardest on the poorest
families in our society the poorest
single adult households are now spending
54 of income after
cost after housing costs on energy now
that is simply not sustainable
the queen's speech is yet another
example of missed opportunities it fails
to fix known problems with universal
credit like the five-week weight the
benefit cap and the two-child limit
pushing more families further into
hardship
nor does it do anything about the
appalling state of pensions in the uk we
have the worst pensions in europe
equivalent to 20 of average earnings
compared to the oecd average of 40
utterly appalling many of our pensioners
now face the stark choice between
heating or eating and the abandonment of
the triple lock on pensions takes
hundreds of pounds out of their pockets
at the very time when energy bills are
soaring through the roof
and they have serious issues over food
security and prices there nor should we
forget that before the current turbo
charging of this crisis when the tories
came to power in 2010 that malnutrition
in the uk has tripled let me state that
again it has tripled one in 20 people in
the uk are affected by malnutrition and
this government's inaction will only
make that situation worse this week
andrew bailey governor of the bank of
england said it's a very very difficult
place for us to be to predict and
forecast 10 percent inflation and say
there's not a lot we can do about 80
percent of it well i'll tell you what i
would be doing about it we need an
emergency budget we need to slash that
on fuel prices and we need to
pose a windfall tax on the companies are
benefited both through the pandemic and
in the current crisis and to my
constituents in scotland i say this if
you want joined up policy making from
government and tackle these issues then
you need to get independence because you
won't get the action here
and the prize for patience and
perseverance
[Music]
goes to zara sultana
the annual profits are all giant shell
12 billion pounds bp's profits 9.5
billion pounds the company's boss
himself has said his pay more than
doubled to just under 5 million pounds
and then the company complains that it
is and i quote getting more cash than we
know what to do with in the next year
the combined profits of these two
companies are expected to double to 40
billion pounds and it's not just the oil
giants bankers bonuses are booming too
higher than any time since the 2008
financial crisis posh bars in the city
say that they've had a run on their most
expensive champagne so while the vast
majority are struggling like never
before the wealthy few are indeed raking
it in the institute for fiscal studies
says the booming incomes of the top 1
are driving rising inequality is a
crisis for the majority but it is a
bonanza for the few and this is not
inevitable this crisis was made in
downing street the result of political
choices made by this tory government
last year it let chow pay zero tax on
north sea oil and gas production with
the treasury actually paying them 92
million pounds earlier this year the
tories voted to give bankers a tax cut
worth one billion pounds a year and then
just a week later we saw them vote to
slash social security payments in real
terms and cut pensions by around four
percent once inflation is factored in a
couple of months earlier they
implemented the biggest overnight cut in
the history of the welfare state
scrapping the 20 pounds a week universal
credit uplift and then they let energy
bills soar by a whopping 54
their choices are why my constituents
and millions of people across the
country are struggling while the super
rich line their pockets and madam deputy
speaker we could choose to do things
differently and that's what amendment f
tabled in my name would do it would use
a windfall tax on all giants to slash
energy bills and bring energy companies
into public ownership it would give
millions of work of workers a real pay
rise making the minimum wage a genuine
living wage and implement a real terms
public sector pay rise it would rebuild
the social security safety net with a
real terms increase in social security
and pensions including restoring the 20
pounds a week universal credit uplift
and it would pay this
by raising taxes on the richest not
ordinary workers including an end to tax
dodging loopholes members opposite are
so fond of including the non-dom status
madam deputy speaker instead of the
political choice to squeeze the
livelihoods of working people we could
squeeze the profit of the rich and
that's what this amendment will do and i
urge members to back it
shadow minister jonathan ashworth i'm
grateful uh madam deputy speaker and
this is a debate about the 250 000
households that the national institute
of economic and social research predict
will be forced into destitution next
year
this is a debate
about the 1.3 million people including
500 000 children who will be pushed into
absolute poverty this is a debate
about the 2 million pensioners in
poverty and rising this is a debate
about the two million adults who didn't
eat for a whole day last year this is a
debate about our constituents who are
working all ours god sends and still
needs to queue at food banks to feed
their families and in the speech earlier
from the chancellor i don't know where
he is by the way uh madam madame deputy
speaker but in the speech from the
chancellor earlier he boasted of the
employment uh miracle but isn't the
truth from the office of national
statistics today that pay is being
outpaced by inflation with real wages
falling by 1.2 percent that's the
largest monthly fall in real regulate
wages in a decade and yet at the same
time for the very top earners on paa y e
they are seeing rapid increases in their
wages labor market inequalities are
widening and workers deserve a fair pay
rise madam deputy medal deputy speaker
but the truth also when you look drill
down into the employment figures and it
has come up is that employment is lower
than pre-pandemic indeed 1.5 million
people have left the labor market more
and more over 50s have left the main
labor market and are drawing down their
defined contribution
pensions and those out for those out of
work at sick for sickness levels of
those out of work is at the highest
level
is that the highest oh here he is
come on come on the sickness levels are
the highest level for 20 years and
instead of help in the gracious address
there was no employment bill it was
ditched job center plus and dwb staff
will see offices closed and laid off and
job scheme funding is being cut or it is
under spent this is a government failing
unemployment madam deputy speaker our
constituents face our constituents face
a cost of living crisis and instead of
action we had a complacent speech from
the chancellor earlier he said he may
act on a windfall tax soon that's what
he said but people need action today
does he really think that those parents
who are making choices between feeding
meters or feeding their children that
those families who are cutting off their
meters those people who are scared of
the final demand from their energy
companies do they does he really think
that they can say to their energy
companies don't worry we will pay you
soon of course not madam deputy speaker
the manana chancellor needs to act today
to help people and a theme across the
house not just today but throughout the
week has been the failure of the
chancellor and the government to help
people with the cost of living crisis
they've been many speeches and i cannot
mention all of them so i'll only mention
a couple but the honourable members for
dudley south and newton abbott and seven
oaks i think made speeches with
sympathetic noises towards a windfall
attacks in fact they were so sympathetic
i thought they'd got hold of the
parliamentary labour party briefing pact
for this debate madam deputy speaker
i've we're very pushed for time i think
that i'd make the honourable gentleman's
uh uh
very very honorable gentleman's partner
but i will look forward to him he could
have a word with me when he's voting
with us in the lobbies later madame uh
madame uh deputy speaker but look at the
realities facing our constituents pasta
is up ten percent milk cheese and eggs
up eight point six percent butter up
nine point six percent cooking oils and
fats up eighty percent and the message
from ministers just purchase supermarket
own brand buy value beans the new free
word slogan from the tory party madame
deputy speaker now another quotation
which the which the chancellor may be
aware of will be milton friedman i know
he's a big fan of his and milton
friedman said inflation is taxation
without legislation but the chancellor
has legislated instead of helping people
on universal credit he legislated to cut
universal credit in real terms a loss of
around 500
instead of helping pensioners with the
pension triple lock the government
legislated to impose the biggest real
terms cut to the pension for 50 years a
cut of over 420 pounds for the typical
uh retiree and the secretary of state
for working pensions is about to embark
on a program of cutting the incomes of
some of the most vulnerable of people on
legacy benefits as i may migrate to the
universal uh credit but indeed it
doesn't it doesn't have to be like this
because as the chair of the treasury
select committee and my valuable friend
the chair of the work and pension select
committees and have many charities and
the ifs have said that you could bring
one could bring forward the benefit
increase penciled in for 2023 or a
proportion of it brought forward to
today because indeed the chief secretary
at that dispatch box a few weeks ago
said that the 2023 increase in benefits
and the pension will in his words
will capture inflation uh they will take
account of inflation so they are
promising to increase benefits and the
pension in 2023 in line with inflation
but in the meantime they're sending the
very poorest on a roller coaster while
our wife where 500 000 children will be
pushed into absolute poverty now of
course the chancellor to be fair to him
did say we looked at this but the it
system said no and of course as many
have said it's a shame the ic system his
computer didn't say no when he was
cutting universal credit by twenty
pounds manager but i've been given uh a
briefing note from oracle
who as i understand provide the i.t
systems for the department of work and
pensions and this briefing note from
oracle madam deputy speaker says it's
titled
how dwp
transformed the backbone of the uk
benefits system
and this briefing note from oracle goes
on to say in the changes that they've
made the computer system
they say they've built automation
into its management
this allows dwp to make changes
every week
rather than having to plan six months in
advance and then and then randomly let
me just finish it i'll give it and then
madame dr speaker
mr mark bell who i understand is the
deputy director at the department of
work of pensions says this has been
widely recognized as one of the best
technical achievements delivered by dwp
digital for many years it also enables
us to make further digital enhancements
to benefit millions of uk citizens and
then mr nick cutting the technical lead
goes on and said this has brought
flexibility he added that it has led the
department being able to do things it
never could have done or that would have
taken significant time at significant
cost if it was still running on legacy
infrastructure so you see madam deputy
speaker the truth is it isn't the
mainframe that is stopping them acting
is their frame of mind that is stopping
them
oh give away our giveaway
um i appreciate that
uh although he used to be a political
advisor to the previous government did
not have universal credit what he is
describing is universal credit a system
which the labour party has consistently
opposed that is why we were able to make
the changes it is true and accurate as
he's just read out to the house that
it's the legacy systems that are the
problem and that is why we cannot simply
change the rates of all benefits as he
wants us to do so the point is
we cannot do
exactly what he and he has read out the
reasons to the house
the writer of lady has just confirmed
that she is refusing to increase
universal credit with a consequence of
that 500 000 extra children will be
pushed into poverty as a result of it
and i remember meeting the honourable
lady for negotiating i am not misleading
the house i remember meeting the
honourable lady for negotiations over
the pandemic legislation we met in the
offices of the secretary of state for
health and we said we needed more
support and universal credit and we came
to an arrangement and the honorable lady
also gave a lump sum to those on working
tax credits which is a legacy pavement
so if there was the will the government
could do it the truth is they don't want
to do it madam deputy speaker now i'm
going to uh conclude because of because
of time but the reality is this
if the government wanted to lift
children out of poverty they could do if
they wanted to live put into this out of
poverty they could do if they wanted to
prevent 250 000 families being pushed
into destitution they could do the fact
that they are voting against this motion
tonight in the lobbies tells you
everything you need to know about this
tory party that poverty and rising child
poverty for them is a price well worth
paying
[Applause]
secretary of state therese cough
well thank you madam deputy speaker it
is an honor to conclude this debate on
the gracious speech and understandably a
lot of people have contributed today
i want to take this opportunity to join
honourable and right honourable members
and paying tribute to her majesty in her
platinum jubilee year
now madam deputy speaker this is a queen
speech that will deliver for the british
people
safer streets
stronger schools
secure supply of energy speedier access
to social security for those people near
the end of their lives
streamlined financial services unlocking
investment
stripping out of unwanted eu regulation
and legislation to help level up across
the united kingdom
all this all these measures will help
grow the economy to help address the
cost of living challenge that families
are facing
now we should remember madame deputy
speaker this is a global challenge
countries around the world are having to
deal
with inflation
and the covered aftershocks
are still ripping through
the world's supply chains
and on top of that
putin's brutal invasion of ukraine has
exacerbated spiking energy prices
on this side of the house we are the
champions of freedom and democracy
around the world
and it is right that we do all we can
to end putin's onslaught
but sanctions are not cost free
for us here at home
and they do come on top of the impact
from covid
madame death speech these are global
inflationary forces and it'd be wrong to
protect
that we can protect everyone from that
impact
thanks to our strong recovery from the
pandemic and having got the big calls
right over the last few years like our
plan for jobs
we have helped families around the
country
now you can see that in the labor market
statistics published today
our unemployment rate today is below the
low level we saw before the pandemic
not only that it is the lowest since
1974.
the number of people on payrolls
is at a record high and over half a
million more people
are now benefiting from a regular pay
packet than in february 2020. i'll come
to the olive gentleman a moment
i'm also delighted today to say we have
met our 2017 commitment to get a million
more disabled people into employment in
10 years in fact today we've announced
we've hit
1.3 million more people that is good
news for people with disabilities and
it's good news for the economy too and
the level of youth employment is now at
a record low this means greater security
more financial resilience and better
prospects for people i give away to the
honourable champion i'm very grateful
indeed to the secretary of state
when i go to my local food bank she
talks about employment but when i go to
local food banks one of the things that
they tell me on a regular basis
is that the number of people using the
food banks who are as a result of
in-work poverty is up
what does her local food bank tell her
well the honourable gentleman is right
to raise that food banks are present in
many communities providing a support
especially when people are
undoubtedly
trying to work out the best way to spend
their resources but in terms of aspects
of that in work poverty that he refers
that's why we have a plan from work
progression that's why we've been
investing in skills it's why we're
investing in our job centers it's why we
through plan for jobs
we are doing more to help people to not
only get back into work but to get on in
work as well and that is what we are
doing
madame dexter speaker on top of the
activity we've been undertaking you know
there are things we can and are doing to
cushion families from the worst effects
of inflation and to ease the squeeze on
household budgets
as my older friend chancellor has
already mentioned and set out today the
22 billion pounds already committed to
support the hardest hit this year
that's a 150 pound support for
households in and houses bans a tod
landing into people's bank accounts
with a further 144 million
pound discretionary fund available to
councils and from october as we know the
200 pound reduction in energy bills will
help families spread increased costs
this year over the next few years
now one things that we initiated was the
household support fund where we invested
500 million pounds across
great britain across the uk in order to
help with the cost of household
essentials we've repeated that so it's a
billion pounds every year and we have
put the focus in particular on the
second phase of the grant on people on
fixed incomes which is why a third of it
is ring fence for pensioners and that's
on top of existing targeted support like
the warm home discount cold weather
payments and winter fuel payments and
we're stepping in at this challenging
time and we are ready to do more to help
now we're discussing an amendment today
from the opposition
mr speaker i want to put it clear we
will reject all opposition amendments to
the queen's speech
as a matter of precedent
this speech sets out the government's
legislative programme for the year now
it's my for my right-hand friend the
chancellor to introduce fiscal measures
and indeed all future decisions on tax
will be made by my right humble friend
in the usual way
and just to reiterate reiterate the
point the chancellor has said today in
the house
no option is off the table
but we know that the best way to raise
living standards over the long term is
to grow the economy to invest in skills
to get people moving into and
progressing in decent jobs and the
latest statistics cut through the charge
from the opposition because poverty has
actually decreased since government
since conservatives came into power 1.2
million fewer people in absolute poverty
poor housing costs than 20 200 000 fewer
children
in poverty and half a million fewer
working age adults and in march we
publish statistics for the first time
combining absolute low income and
material deprivation among working age
people
they showed a four of three percentage
points falling from 3.1 million in when
we came into power to 2.2 million in 20
19 20. i give way to the honourable
general uh i thank her for giving me
just back to one home discount
continuously in the house how much money
the treasury puts towards the warm home
discount
yeah the honourable gentleman is trying
to be clever he knows the answer is
that's a redistribution within the
energy policy but nevertheless it's a
policy would he rather not have it would
he rather have been with his fellow snp
people who voted against any up rise in
benefits at all
[Applause]
that's what several of his colleagues
did didn't didn't vote for a lift at all
in benefits
so with the decade of racing employment
clearly an important factor i'll give
great shortly to and behind this
we are building on our track record
ensuring people have stronger incentives
to work and can keep more of what they
earn
1.7 million working people on universal
credit are a thousand pounds a year on
average better off following our cut in
the taper rate and last month 6.6 rise
in the national living wage has provided
the lowest paid with a thousand pounds a
year increase their income and this
coming july the increase of the national
insurance threshold will benefit 30
million working people with a typical
employee saying over 330 pounds a year
i'd give way to the honorable i'm very
grateful to the secretary of state for
giving way she's just been talking about
today's labor market statistics well she
confirmed that they show the number of
people in in employment now is half a
million fewer than before the pandemic
i'm confident in saying on the basis of
our payroll administration which the
chief statistician said is the better
way of understanding and when i've had
discussions with him in terms of more
people are on the payroll than ever
before that's good news
one of the things i'm conscious about
one of the things i'm conscious about
is that there are people who are
economically inactive and that is
something that the government will be
setting about how to tange that as a
right honourable gentleman knows
my main priority is about those people
to whom we pay benefits to look for work
to make sure they get into work but of
course we will be extending our activity
to try and get people back into the
marketplace who have dropped out since
uh covert pandemic
so madame deputy speaker
as i pointed out 30 million working
people will be
benefiting from the rise in the national
insurance threshold
in july and with a record number of
vacancies in the economy we want more
people to have the benefits that work
brings that's why we're focused on
getting more people into and progressing
in jobs where they can boost their pay
their prospects and their prosperity and
building on our plan for jobs our way to
work scheme is getting people into jobs
even more quickly with the aim to get
half a million claimants into work by
june
it's no secret we can see a kind of
magic in our job centers as people
really want to break free from that
unemployment poverty trap and by the end
of april we were more than half of our
way to our goal and we know there is
more to do
but way to work is helping people to
move into any job now to get a better
job tomorrow and build a longer term
career and to help people lift off at
work under job we're rolling out extra
support for claimants to build the
skills they need to progress in work
all of this is underpinned by our
programme to deliver on what parliament
voted for in 2012 that is to replace all
the legacy benefits with the universal
credit because you will always be better
off working than not working unless you
cannot work and that is the magic of
universal credit unlike the cliff edges
of tax credits which stop people
progressing the amount of time
and uh skills they get in work so we're
getting on with it and having resumed
the process to complete the move to
universal credit by 2024 given we
estimate two thirds of people on tax
credits would receive a higher
entitlement on uc this will be important
to help increase incomes all of this
stands in contrast those in the
opposition benches who i think the
leader of the opposition at the moment
would scrap universal credit it was
certainly in his pledges to be elected
as the leader they would undo a decade
of progress and leave people further
from the labour pocket and p in that and
penalize the taxpayer by failing to
realize the benefits of a modern system
madam deputy speaker
my right honourable friend the prize
minister summed up our focus in his
speech last tuesday when he opened the
gracious speech
jobs jobs jobs
high skill and high wage jobs
these are clearly challenging times but
we will continue to provide the
leadership needed to rise to these times
continuing to drive up the skills our
economy needs and employment prospects
across the country
putting more pounds in people's pockets
this queen's speech will grow the
economy
level up our country
spread opportunity
and strengthen security and prosperity
for all the british people
through the covered aftershocks and for
decades to come
mandatory speaker i'm conscious that we
want to continue to commend the gracious
speech unadapted
to the house
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you the question is
that the amendment be made as that
opinion say aye aye
of the contrary no no
[Applause]
clear the lobby
services
the question is that the amendment be
made doesn't matter that opinion say i
of the contrary no no
tell us for the eyes mary glyndon and
colin fletcher tellers for the nose
gareth johnson and michael tomlinson
foreign
foreign
[Music]
um
is
yes
okay
foreign
on
so
um
[Music]
no
so
yes
whatever
i'm
[Music]
uh
lock the doors
okay
uh
thank you
women's is
um
oh
no one wants
it
yes
[Music]
the eyes to the right 248
the nose to the left 310 so the nose
have it the nose have it a lot
what
will the right honourable gentleman just
wait for a moment please
order
order debate to be resumed what day
tomorrow
they should be resumed
tomorrow
point of order sir christopher chip
man deputy speaker on a point of all the
last thursday the uh minister
responsible honorable friend for corby
assured us that the passport office
service
was going to be set up in paul collins
house
so that
members of parliament and their staff
could get quick and easy access to deal
with
urgent passport cases
that service has been set up but can i
raise the issue as to the number of
people staffing that service because
today there was a very long queue
of people waiting to access the service
and some people were having to wait for
over two hours before they were able to
be
get their questions dealt with by by the
officials
there
and
this is
issue is compounded by the fact
that the passport office nationally
is still failing to deal with telephone
inquiries in a timely fashion i've got a
constituent who's written to me today
saying they have spent 25 hours
of their life
on hold trying to get through to the
passport office and this is a case where
they wish to get a passport to enable
them to go
for a family
funeral overseas and the only reason
they need a new passport is because
their old passport was cancelled by the
passport's office
in error because the passport office
transposed incorrectly information from
somebody saying they wish to cancel
their their passport unfortunately that
applicant's passport wasn't cancelled
but my constituents was this is
intolerable what can be done about it
[Laughter]
i thank the honorable the writer jacob
for his point of order
and i have to say that sadly it isn't a
matter for the chair
i say sadly because we are all aware
of how difficult it is to do any
business with the passport office
and we all have large numbers of
constituents who are waiting for
passports and who have been waiting for
far too long
um i hear what the honourable gentleman
has said
mr speaker
would be um
very concerned
that
uh that undertakings have been given
here in this house and then not followed
up
and uh all i can do is facilitate the
honorable gentleman's point of order
explain that it is not a matter for the
chair but express my earnest hope that
the treasury bench
have heard what the right honourable
gentleman has said
and will take the necessary action
soon
thank you
we now come to motion number two on road
traffic minister to move formally
the question is as on the order paper is
my that opinion say aye
the contrary no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it and so we come to
motion uh i propose to take motions
three to eight with the leave of the
house together
emotion number three on the
environmental audit committee
a motion number four relating to the
joint committee on national security
strategy
motion number five on the justice
committee
motion number six on the public
administration and constitutional
affairs committee
motion number seven on the science and
technology committee
motion number eight on the transport
committee
and i call sir bill wiggin
to move the motions thank you madam
deputy speaker and i shall be as quick
as i can because i know the whole house
is waiting to hear from the honourable
member for chrome language so with that
in mind madame speaker i beg to move
the question is as on the order paper as
mayor is that opinion say aye
i think the eyes have it the eyes
have it
i beg to move that this house do now a
journal
the question is that this house do now
adjourn dr kieran mullen
thank you madam deputy speaker i'm
grateful to have this opportunity to
talk about this incredibly important
issue whilst the topic is very broad my
speech today is very focused i'm seeking
to encourage the government to move
forward rapidly and in a robust way with
proposals for home detention for people
that don't pay child maintenance
something i have concentrated on
campaigning for in my short time here
when discussing this issue we are
talking about the most important
building block in our society the need
for parents to take responsibility for
their own children the overwhelming
majority of parents do exactly that
whether together or separated they take
care of their financial responsibilities
my parents are divorced and had no
bearing whatsoever on both of them
continuing to look after myself and my
siblings but sadly not every parent does
as a conservative i'm of course wary of
the state's involvement unnecessarily in
family life it's disheartening that the
government has to be involved in this
issue at all and whatever failings i
might go on to talk about unlike
campaigners who put all their effort and
energy into blaming the government for
everything the people who most deserve
our frustration and anger are the people
not living up to their responsibilities
but unsurprisingly that sort of campaign
doesn't get brand endorsements and
social media favor but one of the things
we all agree on this place is that part
of the role of the state is to penalize
the worst kinds of behaviour when that
behaviour is beyond the pale
we do this most commonly in criminal law
but we also have civil law in both we
right wrongs and punish people who
behave in a way that the rest of society
has decided we won't accept
let me be clear people who don't
contribute to the upkeep of their own
children when they could are in my view
the lowest of the low but there is
absolutely no system of punishment for
that do we really think that as
unacceptable as it is graffitiing a wall
or vandalizing a park bench are more
grave offences than having children and
refusing to contribute to their upkeep i
think the latter is one of the most
deplorable things you can do but as i
said absolutely nothing is done to
punish people for that nothing
we actually find people who don't send
their children to school we punish that
but not failing to support them and of
course in a completely perverse contrast
if you take the much more onerous
responsibility of actually having
primary custody of your children and
neglect them you are punished what kind
of contrast is that what kind of message
does that send because for all the tough
talk about sanctions which i expect the
minister will cover all they're aimed at
is recovering monies owed to children
and how is even that narrow approach
working
certainly there has been some
improvement as described by a recent nao
report the department collected a record
54 million pounds in the quarter ending
september 21 the percentage of paying
parents contributing more than 90 of
ongoing maintenance during a quarter
increased from under one-third in march
2016 to around half in september 21. and
i will
mr speaker thank you
for crew and that twitch for bringing
this forward child maintenance arrears
in my constitution as a massive issue as
it is for the normal gentleman as well
but doesn't remember or not agree that
with the cost of living crisis
with single parent families are under
more pressure and that the 20 000
children in northern ireland alone whose
cases are with the cms advisors deserve
an up-to-date functional service to
ensure that payments are adequate
correct and timely
i thank your judgment for